two
what up everybody
it's june 15th
wednesday here is ethan cline
sorry not beautiful it is wednesday
it is
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
man i would like to see a tutorial of
how you just the thought process that
goes into those acts those are all you
right yeah that's all me that was a
great one thank you thank you i'm
wondering if we can phase out the
gunfire okay i can uh i can try
something different you know yeah it's
been long enough you're right all right
but the it's wednesday gets me every
time because it is wednesday that's why
it's so funny it is wednesday
man
not beautiful
sorry not sorry sorry not beautiful
today's episode is sponsored by honey
sorry we were so late going live you
know uh it's bring your kid and pets to
work day to day
and it's pure chaos actually
so
yes
fun and cute though
um obviously the title as much fun as
we're having here at the top of the show
the title is a little bit foreboding
uh well
i'm actually really sad to say
should we do it should we just do the
announcement now or should we wait
i think we should wait it would ruin the
vibe too much honestly
it's sad man while the crew is breaking
up
someone
i mean
the crew is breaking up what can i say
some
[Music]
they're going out to do their own
project
[Music]
which is fine you know i support that i
think it's great
i think you know
if someone wants to go their own way
then i support them 100 and i think we
should all support them and just be
happy
for the time we had
should we take a vote wait let's take a
vote
which of the crew members do you think
is leaving
i know exactly who they're going to say
and they're probably right
[Music]
let's do us let's do a vote who do you
guys let's put
well let's just be honest we know zack's
not leaving zach will never leave okay
olivia just got back so she's not
leaving so between dan
a.b
ian
and
cameron or love options on the poll
well it's obviously not camera or love
since i was like cameron or love
so sam but it's obviously not sam [ __ ]
all right it's either a b dan or ian
who's sam
stop it
[Laughter]
don't make me relive that
zack
yeah i'm just curious what people think
you know and like i said
not everything's forever
and um
[Music]
why did you add that as a fourth option
dan that's [ __ ] ridiculous
that's not true why are you misleading
them
wait why did you do that dan
[Music]
it's not the fourth option dan is being
a dick
[Music]
dude you really [ __ ] up that pole
dude
sorry
such a bad moment to make you know
what's interesting i thought for sure it
would be a b just because you have your
own channel stuff
but actually the the winner right now if
you ignore stop trolling
is ian
he people think ian is fed the [ __ ] up
thoughts on that ian
i don't know why
they think you're leaving
i'm here
so you're not leaving dude
i thought it was going to be a hundred
percent me yeah me too i thought it'd be
for sure ab tyler donations
baby dan is leaving to be the producer
for fresh and fit also dan i don't know
if this is interesting to you but you
got the least amount people are least
convinced you would ever leave me dan
that's because they know i'm a real one
you know they call me dan the hater but
they know deep down i don't know why
people think i can ride or die baby
uh
by january i will have been here for
five years mm-hmm yeah you're tired of
it half of them admit it i'll be here in
five years i think we've been here five
years you and dan i'm here for five
years
like i think like next week is that
right
yeah i have i should have everyone's
anniversary written down but you guys
started around the same time right i
started uh probably three months before
ian yeah i started interning in uh
august but i wasn't like full-time until
december right and i that's the thing is
i
officially came and worked for you
full-time in july
but
i came and started
switching the show and everything for
you guys it was late june
so yeah yeah it's incredible how you
guys like so and then zach has been here
quite a bit a long time coming up on
four years and that's incredible thank
you guys for your loyal service and even
a b who's seen who's in her newest
addition how long you've been here
i don't say two years august will be two
years what yeah same here
in august too dude you guys moved here
two years ago that's crazy yeah time
flies it still feels like you're the new
guy kind of
sort of it is weird because between me
and zack there was like a what like two
year gap and then after me we have added
like four more in the past year
that's nuts right you said abs your
latest edition but we we have like four
more people right
that's i don't know yeah i think i mean
it feels like he's new still but at this
point he's a veteran sam's been here way
longer than you and i'm yeah i'm the
middle child the awkward
yeah exactly
well the truth is
that um abe is leaving yeah
he has decided to pursue his own solo
youtube career and you know we support
him from that
i appreciate that
and uh two years together is i'm just
happy that we had this time together and
um
you know i'm always gonna support you
bro thank you oh [ __ ] yourself you
stupid piece of [ __ ] abs
keemstar on the other hand
yeah
sorry and i'm gonna miss lina too man
she's the best
yeah she's she is she going with you or
she's coming with me okay
convince her but
it was cool of you to let him keep using
the name h3 though ethan
no you can't use h3 oh that i thought
i'll sue you if i do that i support you
hell no bro star killer
from h3
or maybe we could do like a prince thing
like are you going to take me back some
i'll yeah
all right we'll talk we'll start like an
affiliate program okay yeah i jump on
that like some fine bros [ __ ]
react or it could be like starkiller
formally of h3 right like a you could um
i guess that's more accurate you could
do h you could do of formally
of h3 podcast okay
that works
[Music]
it should be planned like phase plan
could just kind of be like this extended
network
no but in truth guys uh
the actual so we're the actual news is
actually much sadder
than that
the real news is that um
bts is breaking up not us [ __ ] and abe
is not leaving maybe he's not leaving no
wow thank you guys by the way for your
loyal uh
your loyal service
of course
no bts is breaking up it's so much
sadder
uh and just raise the hearts guys if you
would please everybody to know we come
in peace
we come in peace bts army
we're army too we're we're the fupa
trooper army we fight beside you
we have a treaties
right
i can't do it
ends down
and uh that's it
yeah you got it dan so the bottom of a
heart is what you're making
right i just the mechanics show me how
you do it
yeah yeah you got it okay all right well
you did your thumb that way but whatever
you think that's what i'm saying oh it
looks a little different wait
this is interesting is it the top of the
heart or the bottom it could be both
the bottom
i think it's the top
oh that is a heart i'm pretty sure
you're making a heart with your finger
yeah you're making the top
like an actual heart i think i guess you
got to use your imagination a little bit
can i ask something unrelated
just people like to beat yes please okay
yeah of course it's about left does love
need his own shot at this point because
his head is bigger than mine
i love it okay bro you've been
complaining about all right
i don't know this is getting on here
yeah
maybe you like it hey listen
guys
this is about bts okay sorry let's have
some reverence please okay sorry and
stay focused on it on what's uh
important apologize to army i'm sorry
army evie did that everyone saw that
you you own one more heart baby
hit him
wait what is that are you doing hey now
i'm doing it just no it looks like
you're going ah yeah you're doing it
it's just italian two thingies i was
distracted by zordon in the background
no no no no no we're not doing italian
no no quick
keep it keep it sincere all right get
out of there
yeah so bts announced
during their fiat festa dinner
celebrating the band's ninth anniversary
they made this tragic announcement that
uh rattled the world
[Music]
and i'm not kidding this this really did
rattle the word i was sad to hear it
wait people are saying they're not
breaking up they literally are hiatus
they're going on indefinitely indefinite
hiatus man do you know what that means
yeah one direction is still on yeah
exactly you know what a definite hiatus
wants a lot of bands going on in
different hiatus it means we're leaving
and we're not telling you when we're
coming back yeah i'm still wearing some
dude
there's still chance why are people
throwing tomatoes what do i do
what the [ __ ] did i do i'm being
respectful king
i don't think they're throwing tomatoes
because of what you're saying about bts
wait why are they throwing tomatoes
because you trolled them all oh that oh
sorry sorry
you really am why did you put that in
the poll i was trying to bail you out i
knew they'd get mad
yeah we do a little trolling i was
trying to soften the blow up we like to
troll no but this is serious guys stop
with the tomatoes let's show a little
reverence for bts vista
uh here
we go
we're gonna get a claim for this i'm
sure
oh yeah
let me mute it
because obviously they're speaking in
korean so we don't always they always
claim us
it's so [ __ ] up the k-pop yeah let's
make it tiny and i'll just
transcribe it
doing the festa
should we get into that
yeah we're going to talk about the
direction we're taking
since the top of our direction came up
[Music]
gathering like this today and shooting
content
i'm so glad we're bts what would i do if
we weren't bts
i'm just happy being together
i started music and became bts
[Music]
because i had a message for the world
i didn't know
i would do after on
that's the name of one of their songs i
believe but then kovac came up can we
just skip a little bit sorry
go through the inter
did they say it yet or when does that
yeah it was time stamped when they said
it basically are you sure because i i
clicked the time stamp and he was just
talking about
[Music]
he was getting to it well i'm reading i
mean this is not thrilling content
i'm i'm trying to just said it we're
taking a temporary
break
uh
we are taking a temporary break now
there it is
can i get maybe your timestamps
sometimes they're a little late
i'll work on that just a note they come
in just a few seconds late i will say i
pulled that timestamp oh i'm sorry that
one's on me i was trying to well some so
somebody's somebody pulls timestamps a
little bit late late or early like it's
too early no it's late like it's after
what i actually if you click on it it
starts essentially 24 yeah i know it's
right let me try it again but you know i
preferred early because then you have
time to participate
let's see let's see 2105. so so i just
clicked it again it says you are a
unique guy
we're taking a temporary break maybe the
problem is you cut it too precise
okay yeah we need a little runway all
right so a little earlier a little
earlier got it sorry
all right it's all good you know that's
why i'm leaving
[Laughter]
so basically our rm explained that after
singles like dynamite and permission to
dance
they felt they lost the message they
wanted to tell the world through bts
which was
as everybody knows
it's
dan
it's
everyone
everyone knows love bts all about love
and uh uni knowledge reigns supreme
knowledge
uh knowledge rational society
of the proletariat over the bourgeoisie
that's approved
proletariat
and knowledge reigns supreme
over nearly everybody with liberty and
justice for all right yeah the pursuit
to life and justice love yourself love
your self love self love big time
thank you for watching and just being
yourself right guys
and community too was a big one
so they lost touch with all that dang
that's sad dude
still getting tomatoes in the chat
gonna have to work on that
the management company behind bts hybe
lost 1.7 billion in market value
during the first hours of trading i'm
not surprised but holy [ __ ] that's crazy
they lost them that much money
uh after breaking the news of the hiatus
um
we're going on a hiatus now suga said
but this is when it gets really
interesting a representation for the
group
told cnn to be clear they are not on
hiatus
but will take time to explore some solo
projects at this time and remain active
in various different forms that sounds
like they're just doing damage control
well
i mean there's probably a lot of music
in the pipe
so i doubt it will be like their last
release as a group um and so you know
they got to kind of
keep that hype going
right
but you know uh
just so you guys know june cook actually
or did i said i hope i didn't say that
wrong
perfectly
perfect june cook
are you making fun of me
no i actually don't know sorry
i think it's jungkook
john [ __ ] is not john [ __ ] love what the
[ __ ] bro chill
[Laughter]
stop throw up the heart stop the heart
get the heart up quick
love you put that [ __ ] up and you
apologize right now
say you're sorry sorry thank you all
hate can be directed to my social medias
bts's
june cook
jungkook
released a new song called
my you all right
shout out there it is guys that's the
big news
did we make it through that
sad sad sad news
sad news man i love bts man i listen to
that stuff all the time
and uh i'm just honestly not having new
music
it's gonna break my heart love those
guys love do you know of any stores
near where you live that might sell a
podium
that you might be able to why for a for
apology for love or
no for him i'll just he's just building
up a [ __ ] up yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
sorry we gotta fire you up
we gotta drop you did yes
it was just his accent okay it was just
exactly john [ __ ]
i'm trying everyone like english is my
fourth language oh my god uh
so yeah language barrier bro that's too
far ab come on yeah someone says
someone says they deserve a break
they've been on yeah they've been doing
non-stop for nine years and that's the
truth you know
that's the absolute truth no all kidding
aside um
yeah i mean these uh k-pop idols get
work to the bone and uh i i have to
imagine after a decade run
um
they have
some uh it's incredible vacation time
yeah well-earned vacation time yeah
yeah yeah they're some of the hardest
working most talented guys in the world
forget it
everyone who works on an oil rig
or like deep sea fishing [ __ ] them they
don't know the meaning of hard work
they work hard too it's it's a different
kind of it's a different kind no i'm
serious [ __ ] them
they think they work hard
they don't
okay let's move on quickly uh the frog
army
the frog now you guys may have followed
this we got a lot of fun stuff to talk
about here today guys lying it's my
conspiracy so the frog guy we've been
talking about this guy who might be
calling causing an ecological disaster
yeah well this girl has made a pretty
compelling argument that he might it
might be fake it's my conspiracy i'm
gonna start oh [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
i think the program you guys lying it's
my conspiracy here's my proof
so we posted the video five hours ago
and basically he's like my neighbor has
to leave there's too many frogs um but
there's a part of the video that i
recognized
this part right here so there's this
part where like all the frogs are like
jumping through this little green area
and i was like i've seen this before
interesting it's from this video
millions of little frogs by g mike g one
two three on youtube
but here's some screenshots so the top
screenshot is from
um the g mic g and then this bottom
screen shot is from the frog army video
that's the same picture so you can see
there's like that little like oh where's
my little like hey thing in both like it
matches up it matches up perfectly he
just took that video from youtube
wild part about all this is that i
recognized that video because i taught a
junior high science class on frogs and i
used that video and somehow
that information was just stored away
until right now when i apparently needed
it
so wait wait wait wait well okay first
of all he definitely stole that clip
but here's the thing he definitely got a
ton of eggs and put him in his pond that
was genuine footage from the beginning
what a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] questioning
all yeah thank you hassan um i question
it yeah i question all of it but
wouldn't someone have found that footage
too now that they're on the search well
maybe they will now they're going to be
on the what's what's his what's his tick
tock i gotta i gotta go look at it now
okay yeah i mean you got we've been
checking on this guy this tick tocker he
said he was growing 1.4 million frogs in
his pool
and everyone was like dude you're gonna
literally ruin your town
the last time i talked about this by the
way people were making fun of me for
saying
asking what do baby frogs eat well
i learned because they'll be like oh the
bugs no baby frogs eat plants too
[ __ ] they're baby frogs they have a
different diet they're omniforce baby
yes dude
how's it bait how's a bit tiny little
vape one millimeter long baby frog gonna
eat a fly
well so hold on
you just said they eat plants too yeah
they all they eat listen
to they say plant leaves and roots water
striders and insect larvae right what
i'm just saying so i said what's in
their diet and everybody everybody oh
dude you're [ __ ] doomed no no no
what that's not what people were goofing
on you for why because people were
goofing on you because you asked what
baby frogs eat and i said insects and
you were like no
oh i did yeah
no you were wondering how they catch the
insects
okay could somebody
could somebody pull the cliff
maybe just sent it all right let's see
let's let's roll it back
oh no this isn't the original clip i'm
sorry this is the clip of the frog
armies uh so here let's check out his
newest video plus a bunch of frog spawns
so i rescued it all until my pond was
full of 1.4 million frog eggs this could
just be stock footage of somebody who is
a frog farmer so this clip seems to be
the stolen one right
uh right here this one this right here
and just all of these shots in general
oh man millions of them yeah but you see
how small they're they're so small i was
like well how'd these how are they gonna
eat
there's not enough bugs around there to
feed them all
so man that's crazy this whole thing was
a
this whole thing was a farce
a bamboozle
but hopefully unless anyone can find
this footage i'm not buying it because
it's possible he used that footage just
for some b-roll to sell it
hmm
i mean i guess it's possible in the
conspiracy but it seems it's impossible
but i don't know once once that one
piece of it got debunked i'm thinking
it's it's in it's in question woolsey's
on everything
it's in question yeah
the weasley little liar dude what a
[ __ ] liar
frog ass
actually really really incredible what
you pulled off though
but until i i do say unless someone can
find
footage of this
of all the tadpoles and stuff
yeah then then i mean they're still
it still could be legit
what a [ __ ] weasley little liar dude
but yeah
somebody said i've never been happier
for something to be not be real that's
true i mean i'm hoping i'm hoping it's
fake yeah me too bad bad bad horrible
you do not want to leash release a
million frogs on your neighborhood yeah
uh
by the way catherine donated five
dollars and said i want to see ethan eat
butter as a sorry for being mean to bts
i wasn't mean what the [ __ ] i was
respectful the army has spoken why
because of their hot single named butter
i assume that that's the connection yeah
i'm not eating butter what what did i
say that was mean about bts i didn't
really think you were being mean either
but i am not
the authority on what is mean
well should we do a bumper group like
bts should should the poll just should
ethan need a stick of butter no was i
mean yes or no
because i wasn't like we know how that
one would go no
ethan mean to bts first of all i'm not
eating a stick of butter so get that out
of your head right now okay so don't let
that affect your your answer to the bowl
because a yes does not mean that the
butter as much as i do love butter don't
get me wrong yeah
and bts
and the song butter the song butter is
what i meant bro okay
was ethan mean to bts yes or no asking
the community right now
stop it you guys know i was respectful
and don't just vote yes because you
think he's gonna get better because no
no we need a genuine answer here thank
you guys
and shame on you to the 37 percent that
said yes because you're lying
thank you guys for saying no
i don't want
to be invaded by army again we're a
neutral
country oh olivia have found
okay and then furthermore
here's here's where everyone was making
fun of me let me know if it's time
stamped too early okay i will
and then if i scroll down i bet the top
comments about like ethan's a [ __ ]
idiot he doesn't know about frogs
uh
it's all about jimmy jimmy stole the
ladder yeah
yeah jimmy is kind of the legend
oh come on it was at the top there was a
i saw him too okay good but yeah i don't
see it now
um
can maybe someone could just find
because they had like 10 000
yeah i have the
oh yeah so here it is let's get to the
bottom of this these are on your own
apocalypse yeah wait so but for real
what do little frogs eat what's their
diet consistency insects and yeah mostly
so they're all going to die of
starvation yeah no they're this is this
is a horrible thing they're they're
gonna all die like 99 of them they turn
the freaking frogs game
back there
going back there
that's it what did i do
i
then that's not what you said happened
that time stamp was way too early olivia
oh no okay okay okay
okay all right it's right after this
okay just let it play okay
i i don't i don't want it i don't want
to make it a thing i'll play it i'll
play the clip well
i thought the time step was perfect
thank you yeah i loved it i thought it
was great
insects how does a little frog eat and
you find insects though are you sure
it's insects can i get a fish
okay
there it is right that being said you
saw how little those frogs are they're
like smaller than a like a
fourth of a fingernail
and it says little frogs eat
well and water crawlers right yeah
aren't isn't that a type of insect and
plants and roots that's what i was
wondering right i guess they yeah they
eat they eat uh water and then they eat
their poo poo they don't eat the poop
they're like these little skimmers that
skim on the right yeah yeah
they're gonna close about
there's an insect
guys he listen this is the show it's
about learning it's about growth
let's watch something funny
this dude told me he was gonna go 450
miles like this i had my doubts and uh
so i pulled out the camera i guess this
is him just leaving on the trip
i love this
he's just pulling it with a rope which
obviously
that makes no sense
that's so awesome dude a total
failure from the first turn
instant
yeah doing a rope is not a good idea
fyi
[Laughter]
dude that's so funny ah [ __ ] love that
great
ace family warns
that uh
we gotta say
ace family warns of impending drama
uh which is pretty awesome they're doing
like
they're prepping everyone for ace fest
and the boxing match and their wedding
you know there's all going to be of like
it's the scamming year for ace family
and they're prepping their fans
they're doing almost some like mega
stuff where they're like yo you're all
about to hear
you're gonna hear a lot of fake news you
guys are gonna you guys are gonna be
hearing [ __ ] like i tried to steal the
election just confessing his crimes out
and open not true
so listen to this oh one more thing one
more thing one more thing one more thing
one more thing
okay so you guys know that we haven't
really been like too much on like social
media lately like we obviously post here
and there we haven't really been filming
we've kind of taken a break we told you
guys that after this year we're going to
take a break from youtube
but i have to say and you heard it here
first right for all of our og followers
if you're watching and you're listening
to this right now okay be prepared for
some just drama some unwanted
stuff just weird by weird energy coming
towards the ace family name in the next
month or so what is she predicting
what's happening in the next month
ace fest yeah right and the boxing match
right those are both right they're both
happening yeah i think so how do you put
on two events like that i mean it's
impossible
uh
without a massive production company you
skimp on
literally every aspect of it and screw
up your fans so um damned
yeah they're getting ready they're
they're they're
they're doing damage control before it
ever happened
it's awesome
it happens like waves
i was wondering do you think they saw us
talking about how we got tickets and
we're going
and and she was like [ __ ] i better say
it's definitely possible yeah i was
wondering that too that was my first
thought because i think they must have
seen how we're like we're going we got
family pack five tickets
he did post something on his instagram
after we talked about them he didn't
like directly reference us but he said
something about haters oh really yeah
cool
no we're just we're just going to attend
the event that's it we just want to
enjoy a great family festival yeah
that's all we want to do
i mean we spent 500 bucks on that [ __ ]
so you better
i just want to be entertained
do we know who's going to that by the
way we have
we have four or five tickets five five
tickets i believe who's going
a b
zack's going we haven't we haven't
discussed it
ian
cam
ian you want to be the uh
you want to chef that that docu
donk you series up
well i just kind of want to go on the
rides and stuff right the free rides
and free food too right and a meet and
greet
with austin and i'm kind of hoping to
get that wedding invitation
yeah the lucky the lucky one yeah and
don't you get something about his boxing
match like you could win something
like uh
take us through his boxing match is that
what you know
it just says that you get to watch his
boxing match so i guess you get like a w
i have no idea
again this event is happening in a month
and we haven't got anything we have not
received any tickets
we have not received any even a uh
information all we got we have the
automated rece receipt from shopify yeah
that should be good enough to notice
that that 500 was deducted from my bank
account
like that's all we've got they haven't
sent us anything
that's incredible well that's all you
need to show up right you say a shopify
receipt you just say you have tickets
right yeah um i reached out to their
support and it says that you just show
your receipt
that's
shopify responsibility i bought tickets
before they switched to doing it through
eventbrite so oh oh oh i have i don't
know i haven't i haven't gotten anything
from eventbrite so all we have is a
receipt literally that's it didn't you
message support and they said something
like how do we get our tickets
yeah they said just show the
confirmation email at the door with
four ids or five ids literally just a
shopify receipt you heard it here folks
ace
just show up with a piece of paper that
says idiot you bought a ticket that's
all you need that's awesome an id what
does that matter you didn't even give
them your names did you
i mean i guess the name on the credit
card
would maybe have to match
well that was that would be your name i
think right dan
uh yeah so i don't know why they need
ids of the four people i'm bringing you
should message them and say yo i bought
this card on my grandma's card she
passed away so she's not going to be
attending with us
and so is that going to be a problem
yeah
i'm going to reach back out to them and
just see what's going on
yeah
the grandma passed away thing should
help you out there
to get a swift uh response
thank you for your support on that
oh yeah
what'd you see her genital region was
exposed dimly it had the appearance of a
thick mat of hair
she was stroking herself absent-mindedly
what is wrong with you she walked over
to me
pubic hair compacted
a large artist's paintbrush
she pushed this at my face
i raised my arm several times to deflect
her hand stop finally
stop
okay tell me what happened now i'm at
the edge of my seat unwilling to hurt
her or interfere with her any further i
let her have her way oh my god she
stroked my face with the brush
no no no no no keep going zach
that's it that's the whole clip wait i'm
fat dude how did you actually record
that and put that out there bro that's
insane
you said grandma and he got started so
you know
the events there's just more [ __ ] thrown
at us just be prepared that that's
coming
don't click these drama um channels
don't click these news outlets because
they're just trying to get you to click
so don't do it i feel like our loyal
that's like trump being like don't read
the news guys
whatever you do
don't read the newspaper guys for the
next month just don't put on the news
you know you'll be good
don't believe anything anyone says about
me
family members already know that but
it's good that you address that i mean
like literally like it happens every
time it's a clockwork it's like
something that i just it's almost like
you guys run a scam every time
i wonder why all these stories about you
guys uh it's such a crazy coincidence
pops up every time
every time
yeah
weird it's not even intuition anymore
it's like no this happens every time
it's literal
forensic evidence we've seen it it's
real and it's there and just don't buy
it forensic evidence that is not you
didn't use that word right no
wait don't listen to it i'm telling you
like it comes in waves positive lives
only positive vibes only since day one
we've been doing that since day one you
guys know us ace family got ace fest
july 9th why are you so far from me and
we have oh july 9th that's three weeks
away
my
fake wife
or maybe wife
i mean are they married yeah they're
married they have kids it's just weird
that they're well you can have kids
without being married and they're part
of the ace fest is that you get to go to
their wedding
no they are married they're getting
married again for some kind of [ __ ]
ticketed event
it's it's nonsense they're married right
abey yeah yeah they're married double
checked out but no it the whole thing is
psychotic the double wedding
weird
i mean what the hell i'm just excited to
go to the lane caster art festival
yeah i know
at least you'll have something to do
there driving all the way up to
lancaster
um
man i got a real treat for you guys
so as you guys know
pnp is america's favorite lawyer let's
go
a bit and we are at uh 38 minutes okay
so let me just set this i'll do we only
have one ad so i'm gonna thank them but
okay we have some fire new pnp
lawyers let's go but the crazy thing
guys
is that we may have found a lawyer on
tick tock that's even crazier
um
this guy
makes pnp
look like
exactly insane
this man is the next one is a literal
demon the people he gets off
so let me just thank our sponsor we have
some great content coming up here also
we have amaranth who's gonna call in she
was shared a really crazy story about a
stalker
who's been stalking her
and just got arrested
some buffalo bill [ __ ] dude it's crazy
yeah it sounds real interesting so
she gonna call in to discuss that and
maybe around uh
maybe around three is that okay
she can see if she's available from that
right now all right let me think our one
sponsor guys hold on one sec here
yes it's honey
today's episode is sponsored by honey
the easy way to save when shopping on
your iphone or computer
i love me some honey if you're not using
honey you're straight up missing out on
free money elo is a shopper she loves
buying stuff online
and we're always shocked these are
genuine screenshots that elast sends dan
every time
uh we get a honey score
dan is uh trying to work that out at
this moment i was i was texting
amaranth's assistant let's go
check this one out look at all these
these are all real savings
and the crazy thing is it's a just a
plug-in you you install it in one click
you don't have to think about it and it
just automatically searches the internet
for the best coupon code
applies it at checkout
and bada bing you suddenly just save 20
that you didn't expect
i mean it's super easy
it's not intrusive at all it's literally
just a plug-in it doesn't doesn't do
anything like weird
it's um
imagine you're shopping one of your
favorite sites and when you check out
honey button appears and all you have to
do is click apply coupon wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons
and confined for that site if honey
finds a working coupon you'll watch the
price drop
i mean it works on clothes tech food
you name it man
they're on like hundreds of thousands of
stores
honey doesn't just work on desktop
either now it works on the iphone too
just activate it on safari
and on your phone and save on the go
that's awesome so if you don't already
have honey you are straight up missing
out on savings and by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a solid and supporting
the show thank you
i would never recommend uh this
if i didn't love it and i do love it i
use it it's on all my browsers okay
honey for free at joinhoney.comh3
that's joinhoney.com
h3 thank you
[Music]
on the real though honey is one of those
products where you're like
what is going on here because it's like
too good to be true
i mean it's so easy to install you guys
use it i'm not even doing stick here
it's like kind of nuts i have it on my
browser i used it yesterday there you go
it's insane how it like
what oh is that you sam what yeah every
time i buy something i use it
it's crazy how like literally every time
you buy something you save it's like oh
[ __ ] it's nuts not even doing not even
doing an ad here just you don't even
have to think about it dude
um
i want to shout out real quick a 50
donation that said don't eat butter
sauce
on putting down ethan eating frozen
pizza
buy frozen pizza eat frozen pizza that's
right can you imagine what a stick of
butter would do to my digestive system
didn't we eat butter and like fruit
loops the other like oh yeah
we did i didn't i was born remember oh
yeah you dip you had a stick of butter
and you dipped it oh yeah i took a
little nipple yeah that got a stick that
[ __ ] was a bomb dude
oh yeah cause the tick tocker who ate
butter sticks right
yo thank you to oreo rusty
who gifted 10
again members thank you yeah he's the
same dude he has to be the yep yeah he
must have like donated over 300. you a
saudi prince or something what's going
on back there
or saudi royalty in the in the audience
thank you
yo zach did you just tweet something
no you just got called out bro uh oh
yeah i see that did you tweet something
right now i tweeted something about an
hour and a half ago
okay that's before the show started yeah
why can you someone fact check that the
time on that tweet uh one hour ago he's
right so how long's the show been going
okay you're good you're good somebody
almost caught you they're like yo zack's
tweeting during the show what made them
assume that it's so funny uh they just
what do you guys think about this barbie
morbidly curious about this whole thing
it's
the whole it's bizarre the cast is like
fantastic and the people behind it are
like
prestige film
like oscar winners
so it's got to have some interesting
angle to it i yeah i'm very curious to
see what is it rated r
that would be epic [ __ ] dude
i want to see a ryan gosling canon
barbie sexy
well if he is ken then his he doesn't
have a dick right or how how
anatomically correct we're getting
dude ryan gosling [ __ ] stud dude he
can be whatever he wants to be
yo so he's playing ken in the barbie
movie
you know i'm gonna make a prediction
they're playing real dolls in a
dollhouse and it's gonna be some like
existential crisis where they become
self-aware and i don't they're not gonna
have like they're gonna he's not gonna
have a dick there's gonna be a scene
where he pulls down his pants he doesn't
have a dick that's a funny gag right
and um
and they're going to be trying to escape
their doll house i think we're going to
see some gosling dong
i think
you're straight up
yeah i think we're going to see some
gosling dong and i you know she's a stud
how do you not show gosling dong dude
he's a [ __ ] stud
agrees i mean he's gotten away with it
this hold on hold on
what was that
i don't know i don't know who's uh who's
uh making all that noise over there
sam's going to check it out
it's gone
dude
yeah you guys come on what was that dogs
you damn do something
so you're calling it we're going to see
his dick you think yeah his dong i'm
seeing people say it's going to be pg
yeah i don't see them putting uh full
frontal mail nudity in the barbie movies
it needs to happen why not it's ryan
gosling guy [ __ ] dude i mean how many
films has he been in uh too many to
count yeah and how many how much dick
have we seen his talk uh not enough see
thank good answer maybe not enough
um people are saying it's gonna be like
truman show that that's what i'm getting
at it's going to have a truman show
thing okay and truman show was probably
pg i don't think that was like a there
was no dong in it now
there was no dogged truman show that i
distinct lack of dong in the truman show
man no jim carrey dong truman show we
sat through two hours yeah what
should truman show which by the way
fantastic movie pg pg there you go
that's it
they're doing a truman show well this
one's gonna be pgd perfect gosling dong
dude
you might have a problem zach
the man has an obsession i mean he's in
one of my all-time favorite movies so
which is the notebook oh no drive i knew
it was going to be drive
the man barely has to talk and he's
badass
it's like some steve mcqueen [ __ ]
damn chill bro drive is the most zach
movie that has ever been made except
maybe like good fellas actually i take
that back
no
well
interesting there you have it um
pray for gosling dawg
like the director what is the director's
name what have they made that could be
an interesting she made um that uh
let's open her uh filmography uh greta
gerwig yeah she made marriage story she
made the oh very little women
okay yeah like i said it's like a
prestige oh wait she didn't do marriage
story the writer did oh the writer which
is her husband or boy long-term
boyfriend
open her imdb dan
so she's the director
yeah so she did lady bird oh wow
which won a lot of awards
interesting okay so so
it's got to be a truman show it's got to
be
oh yeah she did the little women
adaptation a couple years ago as well
that uh
did pretty well who plays barbie is that
what's your favorite
robbie okay yeah dude the whole cast is
crazy like it's it's like a [ __ ] aaa
list click the cat the crew i want to
see who else is in it i think will
ferrell's in it as well really legal
farrell is in it um
margot yeah michael sarah kate mckinnon
will feral the [ __ ] michael sarah yeah
oh so it's gonna be a comedy
i i mean it is there are a lot of funny
people in it i think it'll be
i think you're right though i think it
will have like sort of a uh
existential weird tone to it based off
of who's writing it because the the
co-writer uh this guy noah bombach
um
is known for like
ian and i were talking about it earlier
and as he put it movies about depressed
new yorkers right like sub-genre right
um but he also uh he co-wrote um a
handful of wes anderson's movies some of
the more funny ones actually and so like
i could see it striking kind of like a
dramedy sort of tone as well there you
have it
it sounds interesting barbie who
expected who would have expected them
we're all hyped for barbie ladies and
gentlemen yep
when does it come out
uh next year okay
i'm predicting there's a scene where
gosling pulls down his pants and he's
like ah
i think there will be a sex scene it'll
be like the sex scene in um
uh team america world police where
they're just like yeah yeah against each
other
totally
someone oh wait wait wait someone just
donated 10 bucks it says uh dylan said i
know for a fact that ryan gosling is a
horrible person oh don't say that what
the [ __ ] my best friend worked with him
on gray man
okay first of all don't get your best
friend in trouble by sharing that
well that was a while they're not gonna
find it yeah yeah but second of all i
refuse to believe it
does seem like it's probably true but
there was that video of him breaking up
a random fight in new york
could have been a pr stunt though can
imagine that he's a good guy ryan dude
he hangs dong he's gonna hang dong do
you think he staged the fight i just
occurred to me but that would be awesome
pr like pull up the phone hold an a b
yeah just like maybe
mine was real i got made fun of for it
but yeah it was
your hero you're a hero
yeah it was a real fire that you started
in that car yeah yeah wait pull up the
um pull up the rhine guys and breaks up
new york fight
yo that would be the best
best pr move ever here i got it
because it was just a little too
opportune like look watch this submit it
to tmz okay
because he had paintings
i saw it from a different angle before
there's ryan there's ryan and a muscle
shirt
he's like hell no
that song from the movies
yo that's the best pr stunt ever though
let everyone else record it
no is it is it that you're like
you're lying you're lying
you're lying
you're lying oh my god it is oh we got
it
follow up from dylan uh she's okay it's
no worries he verbally assaulted a
fellow actor on set went against stage
uh choreo choreography
uh and disrespected her team
well
that's interesting it's the t ryan
gosling there's the t yo that would be
the best pr though wouldn't it yeah and
it's so easy to do
to like fake a fight and then come back
or whatever yeah yes
didn't
i hmm
if i miss remembering this story but
didn't donald trump do that doesn't he
have a story where he like supposedly
jumped out of his limousine
and like stop somebody from being
assaulted or whatever and then it all
turned out to be a lie oh my god i
haven't heard that but that's amazing
let me
i might be getting the details wrong but
trump had something like that but people
are saying
i don't think they they had other people
film it you know what i mean because
obviously everyone freaks out i don't i
don't really think it's a conspiracy
theory but it would be awesome pr move
wouldn't it
maybe i should break up a fight no yeah
we should set that up for you
i wonder if we can make that go viral
nobody will recognize me
you walk in the streets stop in traffic
hey
it's like 11. there's like a huge
muscular do i knock them out
walking out from down
you know because you ate at denny's
outside of denny's yeah
never been there in my life
are you looking for something what's
happening
um yeah okay in 1991 trump reportedly
stopped a bat-wheeling attacker in like
central park no jumped out of his limo
and then knew and then i'm seeing new
witness blasts trump's claim that he
stopped the fight
witness deflates trump's claim that he
stopped the bat beating
it was just like a total pr stunt dude
that's like some dumb [ __ ] from a movie
yeah
no way
hey dan that's not bad huh dude trump is
so
anyway let's move on to pnp we love him
all right so here's pmp's new heat but
then i want you guys to gauge against
the new lawyer
and tell me who's gnarlier okay here we
go core in downey with my amazing client
here now he was charged with the dui
causing injury
and a hit and run causing injury and
these are a lot more serious than the
typical dui and hit and run charges
because they at least carry a one-year
license suspension requirement if he's
convicted so he wasn't going to be able
to drive for an entire year if he was
convicted of that it was alleged that
he was at a party and he left the party
to go get more alcohol and that on his
way back from getting alcohol he crashed
into six other cars and ran away and
came back to the party the police came
to the party afterwards he came out
and
uh it's alleged that he admitted to have
drank before he left the house just
telling us what the [ __ ] he did
it's like way too detailed let's go
it's alleged that he had a crazy night
you guys he turned the [ __ ] up allegedly
hit six parked cars and people he hit
people and said it caused injury
then hit and run back to the party and
conf and then he the best party goes he
confessed his crime to the police
and he admitted that he was the driver
at the end we got an amazing result that
we're very happy about
uh what happened to the dui causing
injury and the hit and run causing
injury charges they take it away i was
happy as
as amazing man good lawyer we have
fully dismissed the best
and he's just taking a reckless driving
all right no dui not even a normal dui
reckless driving mm-hmm and a
hit-and-run
no it's just reckless wait it's not even
wet does wet imply no they didn't even
get a dui
oh so wet means that you're drunk
too much wine no wet does but he was
reckless he didn't get the web part
right that's what i'm saying i'm just
making a joke about kavanaugh
yeah yeah
okay so you guys think that's pretty
crazy right
this next one is gonna blow your ass out
now a little bit of a trigger warning
because
this guy
he he got off was facing 99 years in
prison for essaying a four-year-old
child now that's grim right that's
horrific
four-year-old yes dude
what the [ __ ]
watch this [ __ ] this man big dog yeah
here it is watch andy and he's pulling
the same thing as pnp check it out all
right d who is the best lawyer jay oma
and why am i the best because he made my
case go away and uh what were you
charged with i got very asexual so
under kid all right of a child right
and how old was a child
and did you do any type of jail time no
no i didn't and uh are you happy with
the results yes yes i am and is there
anything else you want to add oh he's
the best lawyer because he fights for
what's right and he knows every single
step that he does
he explains it even more to be a better
lawyer and knows his right step to be
like to fight for what's right for your
safe
he's not going to give up like like any
other lawyer he fights for what's right
all right okay so wait wait i guess you
if you read the description he wrote
it says
case gone
another satisfied client client was
facing 99 years in prison time for the
charge of aggravated essay against a
four-year-old child
[Music]
you see the comments yeah the comments
are like he did it
he did it for
sure it really puts pnp in perspective
pmp is doing the lord's work out there
compared to this guy people like yo you
should have kept this one in the draft
yeah for sure you didn't have to post
that dude well and also he's bla like
this guy let's say he's innocent or
guilty or whatever
dude you just put out a video with the
guy's face saying he r-worded a
four-year-old child you know and the
beauty about pmp if you notice in all of
his videos his clients were wearing
masks
so you can't do it
that's interesting not all of them not
all of them or majority people are
saying are is this real it is real and
he he's actually a prolific content
creator and we have a ton more videos
from him and this guy deals with like
major criminal [ __ ] this ain't no dui
stuff that's other silicon is bro ain't
no way he agreed to post this
definitely still guilty no way shouldn't
get this one in the vault
i mean what the [ __ ] dude that [ __ ] is
nuts
uh here's another one
three counts of murder okay jay who's
the best lawyer wait this one's three
counts of murder bro okay who's
what
they just keep getting better and better
hold on this one says
client paid zero dollars to get out of
jail cause he charges three counts of
murder
and six counts of smuggling of persons
jesus [ __ ] christ
let's go
what let's go
okay tick tock [ __ ] you to hell what the
[ __ ] all right so let's see this i
haven't seen some of these here we go
how do you get off on murder
and smuggling people
okay jay who is the best lawyer
his vibe is so much worse than bmp
it's like a shakedown he's like who's
the best lawyer why am i the best lawyer
right yeah at least pnp is respectful
he's like my great client here
this is like a call me daddy situation
he's also like
not trying to get too close you can he's
like
dude they could get him at any second
right right right let's not go yeah
that's right that's fine let's know
let's stay stop let's no
anyway let's see this guy got three
counts of murder six people keep saying
fake
no
he's like literally in prison talking to
his clients through like this is not
fair this predator google reviews i
called his office you did yeah oh well
no he's real look at he's done this a
lot and this guy predates pnp or at
least he was doing it before we ever
mentioned
pnp this is from last year
2021
this is the real [ __ ] you guys
[ __ ] off dick duck you [ __ ] dumbass
app thank you
all right ready
okay
and why am i the best lawyer
because you took me out from jail and
what are your criminal charges
three three death and three illegal
so three separate murders
okay and um did you have to pay for
anything to get out of jail
no
no
okay uh would you recommend me to your
friends and family
[Music]
okay are you happy that you're free and
able to celebrate this guy's a piece of
[ __ ]
[Music]
okay
is there anything else you want to say
to the camera
i did it
you can say it now
okay
um
yes
she is the best lawyer
he is
you can trust him
he's the best lawyer
okay guaranteed
yo if you can get him off three murders
and six kidnappings he is
dude he really milks it too damn and
they're under a gazebo how crazy is that
what the [ __ ]
it's a good lawyer dude six
three murders
and six kidnappings
it must be either
yeah they're under a gazebo this gazebo
it must be like gang related or like uh
cartel related or something but
that's what i'm assuming with three
murders six kidnappings where does that
even happen but either way [ __ ]
incredible man
pnp wouldn't even touch that [ __ ]
this next one client was charged with
trying to kill multiple people
on different occasions
while out on a felony bond
that's [ __ ] wild dude
dude
all right eh oh my god this one's
amazing you guys
he's doing it through the [ __ ]
he's doing it through the visitor's
glass
you guys still think it's fake
yeah i think it was wishful thinking
from uh bro he's literally doing
it through the glass this is too much
for me
all right let's see what's happening
here
all right hey why am i the best lawyer
man because you do the unbelievable you
do god's work
i don't know anybody that's messing with
you you push the hardest you're
consistent you're always pushing you're
pushing you're pushing
[Music]
right now i don't even know what to say
so how many charges do you have i had
five charges and were they involving uh
a deadly weapon all deadly weapons all
aggravated so i've been to prison before
for aggravated charges and this is just
unbelievable right here is that i don't
even know there's no words to explain
how man you're the best so what was the
bail that i got you on you got you got
you got all four you got all my other
bonds reinstated and then you got me 150
000 but that's a that might sound like a
lot to y'all but that's impossible
coming from where i've been and what
i've been through and the cases that i
got all right no way all right this is
the man right here sounds good this is a
that's a billionaire lawyer right here
all right
sounds good um so i'll see you when you
get out yes sir most definitely all
right do you have anything else you want
to say to the people out there man just
stay out of trouble and if you get in
trouble you need to hire jay owner
you're going to get
do it
you know what's interesting that none of
people are like i just want to say i'm
innocent
no they're all like yo this [ __ ]
got me out
dude
another satisfied client client was
charged with trying to kill multiple
people on multiple different occasions
let's get this man out of jail pronto
let's go you keep you keep cutting off
right before the end does he have a
catchphrase no all right sounds good
well
his opening is like who's the best
lawyer in the world
actually that's a pattern with it he has
a flyer that says in quotations i will
fight to get you off
let's just catch for excuse me
i like the double meaning of it
you want to think about it a little
longer this guy's not a showman like uh
pnp you know what i mean yeah
but the charges are unprecedented
this next one
um
what is this
oh that was just the catchphrase right
there
and that's his law degree that he posted
i will get you off i will get you off
and then and then this one says
this is his law license you got should i
show this he put on it's on his
instagram it's on his instagram
here you go guys
um
he is a real attorney
okay
well
i mean
some of these people might be innocent
yep
it makes it a little bit easier to
stomach if you just assume that they
were like wrong fully charged or
something
sure that guy was accused of uh trying
to
kill many people on many different
occasions i'm sure they could have got
that wrong like seven times maybe they
got the wrong guy
i mean maybe
yeah it's not like he's in jail for a
previous felony or anything it's a total
stretch
this one is driving while intoxicated
and resisting a rich i mean who cares
that's like peanuts
that's p that's pnp level yeah that's
let's take a look who's the best lawyer
my man
right here man and why am i the best
lawyer he got two of my cases dismissed
all right and what cases were they man
they hit me with a dwi and uh
and a resisting arrest and how many
years of jail time are you looking at he
was trying to throw two years at you boy
man
two years would you recommend it to your
friends and family wait what the [ __ ]
they were going to give them two years
for dui
resisting arrest might be
multiple times also but also i mean it
is texas which is i mean they're pretty
uh
well he's doing the lord's work in this
case he's hardcore absolutely got both
of them dismissed all right i'll let you
board and is there anything else you
want to add man this dude right here
he'll go to war with you
whether he's playing football or kicking
butt over here in the courtrooms his boy
he's he's does the dang thing he's he's
a true soldier for you man trust me your
family attorney now bro
thank you thank you texas
second time dui maximum jail sentence of
12 months so
it said he was resisting as well oh
that'll there you go
a client was facing 12 years prison time
for forgery fraud and possession of
marijuana four pounds of marijuana
all right w let's go um so you sounds
like a good time wondering why i got you
on video right so i just wanted to
inform you
that i got all three of your cases
dismissed
wait wait wait wait are you really
breaking the news to her on
this man has no shame dude bro you that
this has got to be some kind of
violation of privacy
this is this is i think this must be
some reportable offense to the bar
well i mean i'm sure he does get their
permission no but you but like to film
this
doesn't he said i know but he just busts
out the phone i know but she's breaking
the news to her i know that's [ __ ]
wild
i'm sorry i gotta watch this again
all right w
um so you're probably wondering why i
got you on video right so i just wanted
to inform you that i got all three of
your cases dismissed
mr jail
that's
lazy here's the paperwork
you had me nervous i was so scared when
i came here okay i mean this one
it's happy sweet forgery frog
weed charges let her out let her out let
her live her life non-violent crime i
mean the most present time the fact that
he's live revealing the case responses
that is a violent crime also he goes he
made her come to his office yeah so he
can make a tick tock with her you could
have called her dumbass she was all
stressed out
holy [ __ ]
let's go
i'm team pnp forever i don't like this
guy yeah
is he a public defender because he
always says that he did it for free and
stuff
so is he i never heard him say that
wait you didn't no he's not a public
defender he's from
he's it says he has his own law firm if
he has his own firm then no i don't
maybe he does some pro bono cases no
he's yeah because he definitely said in
the earlier ones yeah i did catch that
too love you're right
maybe you just no he was talking about
their bond
he got rid of their their bond oh maybe
okay yeah no this guy doesn't work for
free you crazy it says he's a criminal
defense attorney and car accident
attorney
he would be great for when we do a um
next content core we could get pnp to be
on the uh
he this guy could be the defense
attorney forever have both of them yeah
litigating against each other
well they're both defense attorneys but
i guess
it's not that serious right maybe it'd
be dope if one sued the other i'd like
to see that play out
oh i got your cases dismissed in two
weeks yes
my dui lawyer was a public defender and
had his own office yeah uh
maybe actually no but or maybe they
maybe they sometimes take public cases
um wait he has his own law firm if
you're a public defender you work for
the municipal
yeah but i yeah i see another public
defenders can also do private work so
it's possible that he sometimes takes on
some okay
okay
shout out let's go states make private
lawyers take on public uh defense cases
yeah okay fair enough if he's actually
doing work as a public defender that's
incredible most public defenders are
like bye see in jail idiot
not working not all yeah we're good
um well there you go we have we're in
stiff competition here i'm team i'm team
pmp forever yeah this guy is a
degenerate but okay
what'd you guys think of that one
that was awesome sick three counts of
murder that really blew my ass off
yeah
absolutely crazy
there you have it huh
again
for my own sanity and not hating
humanity i'm i'm just
i'm just going to pretend like all those
people are innocent and yeah good thing
getting them all off there you go yeah
totally that guy definitely
went separately to 12 people's houses
attempted to murder them all
maybe if they got the wrong guy
possible
happens all the time wrongful they
arrest the wrong person
there was like a hundred eyewitnesses
that
identified him
all right moving on
shout out real quick since we're in
between stories damn when will the teddy
fresh beanies that you're wearing be
restocked been waiting forever fam um
i don't know i mean this is a really old
one
we are restocking the plastic ones
they'll be here i don't know when but i
know they're coming
um
so
stay tuned i guess by the way speaking
of teddy fresh
this dope ass shirt
is on teddyfresh.com
teddyfresh.com don't ask stuff
[Music]
my man look at this
my man misdemeanor
felony
federal crimes
bail reduction i think that's what he
was talking about he just said
you didn't have to pay to get out of
jail no bail right sure uh drunk duis
drug charges theft assault sex crimes
this picture yeah i was getting i was
look going from sex crimes to his face
back to sex crimes and back to his face
these are all things that he's done
yeah
and
that's why i know intimately
and more this is his rapture and
this is i cropped this to leave his uh
to leave his number out of it but
either way same same effect
god lawyers are interesting breed man
that's an interesting breed of folks
yeah i'll tell you hey man he'll get you
off
yeah and he'll get you off on top of
everything and it'll jerk you off
the table
yeah what the [ __ ] there's like a
massive section about this guy ezra
miller
who
yeah he played like uh the flash the
flash yeah and did anyone watch him
portray the flash you did it was in the
zack snyder yeah he was in the justice
league oh that flash yeah
oh really
he was also in perks of being a
wallflower that's what i know him from
and and
oh i see what happened to him he really
lost his mind
you're about to see
so i guess he was doing pretty well uh
uh creatively
as an actor very successful he was like
a critical darling for a long time too
yeah yeah i mean
ezra uses they them pronouns oh okay we
did not know that
i didn't know that
okay well
they uh they
are
they
were a very successful actor
and then i'm sorry i don't know if i'll
be able to keep it together this whole
because this is a very long section so
apologies in advance if i call him if i
call they him
thank you
um
let's see ezra miller is being accused
of grooming a now 18 year old from the
age of 12
as the parents seek court intervention
uh oh that's a new
yeah they call him the flash because he
gets to him quick before they turn get
old enough
i'm just saying they call him they call
me the flash
hey do you guys want pizza from next
door i'm gonna tell you lena can you
bring over all the leftover pizzas
let's go can you bring over the pizza
for us if everyone's done with that over
there
awesome he has no pizza experience come
on you guys thank me thank me
thank you thank you nobody wants it for
me nobody wants it but me right
thank you
i i said grab it all because i was going
to say can you grab me some slices
this sounds less pathetic
it's for everyone it's for everyone yeah
good question i'd crush some pizza right
now honestly
[Applause]
i mean every time you guys talk about
food it's like 1am here and i never can
never get some for myself it sucks
there's no late there's no late uh nah
my city sucks like that it's like
mcdonald's or burger king this time
see
so ezra miller
flashes his way into those panties
he's the flash why do you think they
call him that
according to court documents
attorney and activist chase iron eyes
what the [ __ ] his name is iron eyes what
is this a marvel ace iron off the marvel
film
why is everyone gotta be
yeah i had to double check that wait who
is chase iron eyes i gotta see what he
looks like
is he wearing like a oh my god
wait
is he native america oh he's native
american okay
that explains sorry that's actually
legit sorry everybody i mean it's a
badass name no that's sick chase iron
eyes
and his wife sarah jumping eagle
shout out those i'll tell you what
native americans they [ __ ] know how
to name a [ __ ] yeah a lot cooler
than damn
yo oh oh oh
ethan i mean
oh i'm ethan
everyone loved this by the way
[Applause]
normal i'd be ethan
i'd be
ethan the
iron iron dong
iron dong
uh that's reserved for rank gosling i'm
sorry that's yeah i don't know it's
reserved for who a ryan gosling
okay
iron
ethan iron uh anus
that's not bad
it's pretty good actually yeah iron anus
i don't know if that's accurate though
well it it and what what i mean to say
is it endures a lot it doesn't do a lot
yeah calisthenics the anus itself is
iron i i would agree yeah because you
could have a weak stomach but the anus
tape exactly yeah that that that's my
point thank you zach
yeah i'll just call i'll just refer to
them as ezra from now on
the iron hairline oh
there you go that's that's it
that's it
thank you guys
i'm going by ethan iron hairline threw
that out there so anyway uh chase iron
eyes and sarah jumping eagle claimed
that miller now 29 has been manipulating
and controlling their daughter
dakota iron eyes
as the two met back in 2016.
they say miller took miller took an
immediate
and apparently innocent liking
to dakota at the time the parents
alleged miller gave dakota alcohol and
drugs
like marijuana and lsd as a teen and
exhibited a pattern of corrupting a
minor
jason sarah said in the document that
miller offered to pay for dakota to
attend college early at 16.
miller would later use that against them
to create a sense of indebtedness
dakota dropped out of school
their parents say to travel to miller's
home in vermont
uh they traveled to miller's home in
vermont finding that dakota didn't have
their
driver's license
bank cards or keys
preventing dakota from leaving on her
own accord so basically they assumed she
was being held there she had no option
of leaving
did they go there their parents said
then
chase and sarah say they are concerned
for their daughter's safety and
well-being
and that miller displays cult-like and
psychological manipulation
they allege that miller uses violence
intimidation threats of violence fear
paranoia delusions and drugs to hold
sway of young adolescents
well unfortunately it seems pretty
believable because as
the videos that we have dude so many
crazy
this is only the tip of the iceberg here
the ezra berg yeah
dakota issued a statement on monday um
so this is in response to her parents
trying to get her back yeah
so she said
um i'd like to make a statement to
acknowledge the tragedy that is the
narrative of the general public and the
assumptions made on my behalf
by family and friends regarding my
stability and otherwise i dropped out of
barb five
school in new york oh
barred five months ago my friend and
comrade william passed shortly
thereafter my mind was incredibly
impacted and i needed space and time to
process the grief
my comrade ezra dude what is going on
over there they call each other comrades
she's referred to two people as comrades
now
it's a badass way to refer to people you
are my comrades yeah okay i'll remind
you dan that communism is illegal in
this country i take it back you're not
my comrade all of you guys are my
comrades just saying you're my [ __ ]
vladimir putin well yeah if you like
communism so much
go to russia
uh russia is not a communist country oh
really
and hasn't been for
pretty much our entire lives
uh china then
okay china work for you i mean that
that's at least more accurate to say
my comrade ezra miller for the entirety
of the aforementioned era has only
provided loving support and invaluable
protection
there you have it
but that's what like um
that's what r kelly's peeps was saying
before that whole thing got busted apart
you know r kelly had those girls in his
in his dungeon and they were
making kind of this the same kind of
statements
yeah very much r kelly vibes with this
yeah yeah totally situation
oh it
did is there any for them
oh thank you so much
wait you guys want some i don't need
three you guys want some pizza
uh i ate right before we started i am
okay oh my god thank you thank you
though
she's the best
yeah she's all right
so here's the video of it wait do you
guys want to say no wait anyone else
want pizza
does anyone else want some
oh my gosh you heated it up
damn let's go we're in the chew zone
people let's go
what was i saying oh somebody just in
the chat uh saying that uh there's
zero chance that ezra didn't write that
statement right oh you think he wrote it
well here's a video of her her parents
think the same thing here's a video of
her six days later
let's see what's in this
hi guys
i'm already looking off camera
oh no right i mean
uh oh all right
hi guys
hi folks um
[Music]
i've become aware
that
some people are saying that my
statements were not written by me
i'd like to clarify
that
they
are in fact directly i'm buying it very
believable nobody is controlling my
instagram account
i don't have a phone right now out of my
own
personal
conviction oh hell no he took her phone
this is so r kelly
holy crap this seems very
uh authentic
she is she blinking morse code
maybe
jesus christ this is gnarly this is
harley's [ __ ] what the [ __ ] um
[Music]
and
honestly
it's really distressing
that
the narrative
of why are you talking too slow victim
in question
is not
being granted
and trust
i worked really hard to
make really clear
what was going on
and if the statements
are
too
profoundly
contrasting
whatever assumptions
i've never seen anyone talk that slow in
my life something is up i mean i don't
know her
so
this woman needs help yeah i mean that
that's my impression as well uh but
life was like a box maybe chocolate
why did you play that they like that on
forest gump talks though i don't know
okay
interesting scary
let's finish it it's almost done yeah it
is scary wait till you learn more about
him you know
those of us have garnered
and have chosen
to carry
i'd like to say that it's nobody's
business
and that no one is owed a story
except the police
this is my life
these are
my decisions
it's my life and i'm disappointed
in my parents
and the press
i mean let's be honest her parents would
be
you'd have to be a lunatic not to worry
when your 16 year old
child
runs off with some random person
and loses their phone so man this is
this is pretty wild yep
not good
so that's what's going on with that but
there's so much more
um
yeah
so let's see here's footage of ezra
yelling at police apparently uh they're
just getting in trouble
all over the place like every week yeah
this video is hard it was hard to
describe but
there's a lot going on here what does it
say for nft crypto yeah well you'll see
that's why
okay sounds good i'm into it
no no
i now assaulted in this bar twice in a
row i film myself when i get assaulted
for nft crypto art what's your name
what's your batch number tell me your
name and your badge number wiki
well
he is not but again i would be well so
your your daughter's with this guy i
mean this person
sorry
wow
ezra full name full badge number one
tell me your name your badge number tell
me your name in your badge if you don't
touch me tell me your name in your back
number now
come tell me your name and your
background
sir come on
people seem confused about the girl
that ezra kidnaps aged she's 18. she
just turned 18 but she's been with them
for years yeah they met when she was 12.
12 yeah 12 years old they met and he
paid for her college supposedly when he
she was 16. and that was like the first
big thing that made her feel super weird
did he actually end up doing it i
thought that he just you just called him
he oh i'm so sorry
i i had written this previously and had
written that i got you slipping olivia
i'm sorry i'm actually very very sorry
you just got asked by ian
i'm over
you're good you want some pizza
no i'm good thank you though okay
all right let's let's just keep watching
ezreal come over here tell us what
happened
was that the interesting part is it more
that was pretty much well
no it keeps going you want to go to like
he's the flash you're never going to
catch
you're never going to catch ezra
he's the fastest person alive they're
the fastest person alive
what's with those people just saying
that that was like a spook scare 131 i
mean just i mean it was like slender man
yeah
sorry
yeah i'm
did we ever get more information about
the nft collection he's apparently
working on they're working on sorry
let me see
wait he's still in
ezra still in the new flash
so yeah this
yeah i don't know what they're going to
do with that because this movie's coming
out and it's like a big deal supposedly
it's supposed to be like a multiverse
type thing and there's even rumors of
like um what's his name michael keaton
coming back as batman no no way
but it's rumored so
everyone watch this part so let's just
see what happens here
it's like to say this one
you changed the future
and you change the past
[Music]
batman
sick
so
that's what i'm saying let's go yeah we
know nobody cares about this character
at all but guess what
batman shows up right now you gotta see
it right take that marvel
um
a separate incident
by the time i'm on the bike guys
stand
by put him in the chew zone send her to
the [ __ ] chew zone ian
[Music]
oh oh
i'm done i'm out of the choose [ __ ]
all
right i'm out i'm out
hold on oh here we go
you want me to take another bite
[Music]
oh somebody in the chat just said i love
the flash dan
there you go the one flash fan
no it's very popular
it's cw right
i don't know his isn't the cw yeah
that's a different version of the flash
so a separate incident took place in
hawaii
the hawaii police department issued a
statement
after arrest happened
stating that miller began yelling
obscenities at people
who were singing karaoke no i'm sorry
this is the same this is the same
incident oh this is the same description
yeah so was he singing karaoke or what
other people
um supposedly he
allegedly spit on a woman oh my goodness
i wasn't clear if he was the one that
was
oh he lunged at a person playing darts
he got out on a 500 bear clearly he had
he had one of these yeah guys
representing him
less than a month later miller was
arrested in hawaii again
this time
during a traffic stop after he
they
allegedly threw a chair at a woman
during a gathering
throwing at chairs pretty gnarly
a few months ago ezra put out a video
threatening the south carolina kkk
that's based
hi um this is a based moment
based as [ __ ]
wait he's taking on the kkk let's go
this is ezra miller uh
aka the bengal ghouls
the mad goose wizard
and um this is a message for the
beulahville chapter
of the north carolina ku klux klan
hello first of all how are y'all doing
um
it's me um
is it safe to say they're not watching
this video
they may have gone around i mean it has
2.5
000 likes not that much views
that's like 20 000 views
um this video was pretty viral this is
okay we upload yeah okay okay
okay okay look if y'all want to die yes
i suggest just killing yourselves with
your own guns
okay
um
otherwise
keep doing exactly what you're doing
right now and you know what i'm talking
about
and then you know
um we'll do it for you if that's really
what you want
okay oh talk to you soon okay
bye
oh my god hi
they got he put them on on warning
the whole kkk
chapter
they put him on morning
well that's based i mean [ __ ] the kkk
right
yeah
he said he was gonna kill them though
that's a bit that was a lot
he said it's on site
he said if you don't kill yourself i'll
i will
then he went around
driving around south carolina
looking for the clan
that's interesting
how do you just
oh disappeared
um
okay
the white knights talking backwards but
what's the red queen up to
again
it's like a psycho spiritual sci-fi
revenge movie it's an indie
i mean he seems to be
a manic right i mean this is like
delusions of grandeur and mania
two years ago
ezra choked a female fan
in a convenience store who came up to
him pretending to play fight
that's not funny but of course it's just
so crazy
so she was hoping to have like a
wholesome fan interaction and he just
like choked her out yep on camera
at like petco or wherever the [ __ ] they
are
yep let's go did you want to fight is
that you know
whoa bro bro
did you want to fight the [ __ ]
i think they think they are actually the
flesh
that was slow man dude that was a slow
it was slow and i mean like i think he
thinks he's being like chased or
something or it's his job to bring down
the kkk
there's something wrong with that man
let's be real
i mean that person yeah i'm so sorry i'm
not doing on on
yeah
i'm trying
did you wanna fight
i mean she's still smiling so he
couldn't be squeezing that hard
nah that's kind of like a shock i think
i think she's just doing that to deal
with it it kind of feels like it it was
a joke at first but he decided halfway
through he wanted to like go for it i
mean that yeah from the fans perspective
if i went up to meet ethan when i was
just a fan and then he started choking
me i don't know how i would respond
either i would probably you'd think they
were kidding yeah i'm like oh this is
he's so funny it probably takes a few
minutes to realize you're being choked
or a few seconds right
i think
she's like
cool
we're going to have a play fight
awesome
this was two years ago too eh
yeah it was a while ago uh yeah two
years ago
yeah she uh yeah he was he was he was
trying to hurt her
a maniac
there's more warner brothers has a
uh pr nightmare with more and more
members of the justice league is that
right
so ezra is a potential groomer amber
heard obviously
most hated woman in america right now
the cyborg guy ray fisher
repeatedly called out warner brothers
and heads of the dc film
such as joss josh
whedon for unacceptable
onset behavior and racist practices
ben affleck
um he's just sad is that is that i don't
know
was that a pr nightmare just sad
pathetic ben affleck i mean this video
happened
yeah thinking about so many thinking
about the time i matched with ben
affleck on raya and thought it was fake
so i unmatched him and he sent me this
video on instagram this is one of my
favorite things even
i just wish things would get better i'm
trying to she did him so dirty though
man
naveen why did you unmatch me
it's me
it's me it's me have you not seen that
olivia no i haven't i just forgot about
how nauseous it makes me it's me it's me
why did you want maxi
it's me
we said that that lined up dude
yeah you can't have the guy playing
batman looking that pathetic yeah
you know what i mean
gal gadot what happened to her
oh no
the justice league is disbanded in uh
self quarantine
and i gotta say that um
these past few days uh got me feeling a
bit
philosophical
um
right there this virus
had affected if you're feeling too soft
too philosophical next time gal
hit yourself in the head or something
get a concussion forget what you're
doing and go back
doing whatever else you were doing
oh lord at least uh
what's his name
i think he
he's cool right everybody everybody
still loves him him and jason momoa are
the only two remaining oh jason who's
the other guy aquaman and superman the
guy who played oh superman's a legend
right yeah henry
yeah yeah those two guys are cool let's
just have them
you know yeah that's it could be a buddy
film right aquaman and superman
well in the the ritual the ray fisher
guy didn't do anything bad necessarily
you're right you're right it was just
he caused a lot of pr nightmare for
warner brothers but right
so we he can he could show up the three
of them yeah aquaman cyborg and superman
that's that's an all-star yeah that's
true
maybe they do like a hangover spin-off
i'm interested in that
i mean superman is a a top-tier hero
cyborg and aquaman
why did you unmatch me
this is what ben affleck says to warner
bros
go ahead zach it's me
why did you unmatch me
so on oh
lord she did him so dirty though
dude i'm so dirty with that
all right so let's have amaranth call in
is she on standby uh uh yeah or what why
don't you uh
where's that video you guys get it set
up
and uh
we'll go from there so here's me
it's it's me
yeah so amaranth had this crazy stalker
i'll read you those tweets and she's
gonna call in him
we're going to talk about what happened
but this just happened this morning
she said i have a stalker who's been in
my area since may 8th
he literally watches my stream all day
and badly mimics everything i do
including asmr
he takes showers
when i'm in the hot tub
in the past i've reported him for
restreaming me but
because he had been traveled all the way
from estonia to my city
living in a nearby hotel i want his
stream to remain up so i can keep a
close tab on him i have a security
system a few pew pew devices and lately
i have had an armed employee living in
the guest
quarters part of the reason i'm taking
this so seriously
is because he has professed that he has
sold all of his worldly possessions
his residence and everything he owns to
make the trip
and he's racking up a mighty bill on his
charge card this setup doesn't give him
any outs
here this is i guess one of his live
streams
outdoors in texas houston alec plus kate
oh that's
that's scary
it's me
yeah it's even scarier than ben affleck
it's good for anyone but especially
someone like amaranth where like so much
of her livelihood relies on live content
you know so
people always know what she's up to it's
where she is what she's up to
um she continues
he's depleted his resources and doesn't
have any options here and i fear for my
life and that he might do something
drastic the police are aware of the
situation they know what hotel he's in
and they have a regular patrol but they
can't do anything
despite his intent to come find me
he has literally made it his twitch
title on his stream find caitlyn and
make her mine
please don't report his account his
streams are valuable intel for my
well-being peace of mind they knew what
hotel he was in apparently he moved last
night different hotel nearby
some people
need
extermination
so is this messages from him
only because you think anyone beneath oh
no he got he went nice guy on her [ __ ]
only because you think anyone beneath
you wants something from you but at the
same time you only want their money and
attention
so who's really the one using people
instead of trying to make connections
you sit there and complain you can't go
outside because you fear someone is
going to recognize you when nobody knows
you you [ __ ]
you have more people from overseas who
know you than you do in america
i'm not going to read this psychobabble
it's disturbing
your content okay yeah but you you guys
can use your imagination it's really
horrific like
nasty [ __ ]
uh and then well where's the update
because this didn't have the update
something happened this morning
oh this is kind of not safe
oh just maybe you can send me the link
right this doesn't have the
let me see
she said
here's the new thread i guess it's from
five hours ago
my stalker traveled from estonia in
europe and came to my city camping out
in a hotel within line of sight of my
p.o box and spent over a month camping
out daily at a starbucks next to my p.o
box
44 days
he psychotically streamed every day
every minute of his excursion internet
signal permitted
everything in real time on twitch
typically to zero viewers but growing as
he gained notoriety his account will get
taken down but he would make another one
maybe using
the alias n plus one
picking up the numerical suffix in his
screen name
by his own admission he went scorched
earth and sold everything and left his
life in europe
to come here on a hopeless and
self-described destructive
pilgrimage
he hawked all of his possessions his
house
and
posted private details like a manifesto
the only thing he brought with him
other than his phone and clothing was a
saxophone and a change of clothing
formal attire
saxophone would appear in a few live
streams of himself playing in public
across from the p.o box
serenading no one in particular allowed
him to carry around
occasional saxophone case though which
made me very nervous
was it plausible deniability to carry
that case around
when it time came
to switch it out with a more lethal
instrument uh stop scrolling
what's down there okay
you'll see but leave it off the screen
for a second ian oh [ __ ]
right so he said um
i tried to be clear while he was in my
twitch chat
i clearly state i don't want him to come
i don't want to meet him he'd say liar
liar fiance
he made dancing videos reminiscent of
buffalo bill dance scene and silence of
the lamb and kept sending them to me it
just shows him she blurred it but eats
him naked in a hotel room really [ __ ]
wild bro
he had you can show it now
he adopted took in a feral cat while in
houston because it reminded him of the
caddies sold to make the journey here
the whereabouts fate of the cat he said
goodbye to it in one video or unknown
he was here for at least 44 days
according to his vlog and live stream
on monday the 13th he streamed himself
as was his routine but he was dressed up
in ominously carrying around his music
instrument case
content's unknown
at the time he changed to the formal
attire he brought
and made the last mile journey to my
house
he ceased he he cased the vicinity for
30 minutes
the cops declined to act
he streamed himself outside my house
slinking around mumbling about how he
knew it was wrong but i have to
when he started trying to break in gain
entry i called 9-1-1 dispatch was rude
cutting the off putting me on hold
took 33 minutes from me calling 9-1-1
having previously already explained the
situation to the closest
police department branch
for the first responders to arrive
unknown
unknown the stalker an armed person or a
group of people
unknown to the stalker she had an armed
person
and other people who she employs
have been over her house for protection
heavily armed behind cameras and
security systems and a big guard dog
i don't want to be responsible for what
would happen if you forcibly gained
egress and with the apparent lack of
motivation for law enforcement at least
in the news regarding shootings to
intercept the cops appreciate that yeah
i have no trouble believing that the
cops were worthless to you
out of fear for their own lives i sat as
the only real option i have he ended up
getting arrested detained
the embassy was contacted
and he is currently not in houston
that's all i can say for now that's
actually
great news yeah no i mean this is a at
least something finally happened but
yeah so she's in the chat right uh she's
in the waiting room bring her up all
right bring her in right now one sec
one moment
go ahead and play the ben affleck sound
bite zach why did you unmatch me
just to set the mood
it's me it's me hello
hey amaranth hey caitlin
uh what the [ __ ] dude so yeah we just
read all your tweets kind of explaining
what happened
yeah so crazy so he is gone he's he's
been arrested is he going to be deported
do you know or no
um i'm not sure i imagine so because
they contacted the embassy so i would
think that's a likely outcome
but i'm waiting for the follow-up right
you can't commit a crime when you're on
a visa that's like an instant bye-bye
right yeah i know it's pretty crazy
it seemed i was kind of struck reading
your tweets just how much you knew about
him
you were following him quite closely is
that right
more of he was harassing me quite
closely i would say sending me videos
and stuff and
always chatting in my stream on his new
accounts and being weird and then it
became
more of a surveillance camera because he
was streaming his every move when he was
in houston so it made sense to check in
on it and make sure he wasn't near me
until he was
so you had someone watching his stream
yeah
and you had it sounds like you have
quite a bit of security at your house
which is good obviously
yeah yeah i do
for sure
so
um
that's good that someone was watching
his stream that was really smart because
that's how you guys knew he was outside
your house right yeah
yeah it's pretty scary stuff though can
you describe what happened when he was
there as much as possible because it
sounds really
intense and i'd love to hear about it
yeah so basically he was walking around
outside of my house you know going up
and down the like the street for about
30 minutes
and uh then he started coming to my door
and banging on it he was saying all the
time like i shouldn't be here i know i
shouldn't but i have to
you know he was pretty intense on
getting in because he started peering in
my window started jiggling with all the
door handles like trying to open them he
would hear my dogs barking and be like i
hear her dogs
she's this this is her
so he was very intent on getting in so
that was really scary because the the
police weren't really
uh taking it too seriously until he was
physically like in my lot right up and
down the street they were just like uh
whatever
took them like 33 minutes to come even
though the police station's like five
minutes away okay you know i had i had a
similar experience with the police where
somebody was
driving harassing us outside our house
and they're like call us when he call us
when he's trying to break into your
house because it's not a crime otherwise
right um it's almost too late at that
point
so so describe what so yeah go on so he
basically at one point is trying to
break into the house
yeah
yeah definitely
he's like forcibly like moving the
handles trying to open it trying to like
push on it and stuff
it's just it's he didn't have anything
with him luckily that he was able to
like break it he didn't like bring a
brick or anything to smash a window but
he was definitely trying to get in
and so what happened did the situation
come to a head like what culminated
uh the police got there and uh they
confronted him and they ended up
detaining him he was like i'm supposed
to meet this girl here it's like even
though i've told him several times like
i don't know you i don't want to meet
you don't come here when he was in
talking in my chat while he was in
houston he was at his hotel he would
type and chat in response liar liar mmm
my fiance
i'm like ooh
severe mental illness clearly yeah
something
so you never had to use your security or
your dogs or anyone in the house with
guns and stuff like that
uh they remained inside because we're
trying to get the police to just take
him
first
yeah because he didn't get in though no
i didn't have to do anything
uh i didn't want my my dogs outside in
the yard because i thought that would
confirm that i did live there because he
was live streaming it you know right so
that's like i don't really want that but
um that was smart not to not to
intervene
and let the police handle it because you
don't want to
you don't want to be involved with him
you know
yeah
definitely is this the first time
something like this has happened to you
um
that i was able to see because i did
have an arson before but
yeah who set my trash can on fire uh
that was either earlier this year or
late last year yeah it was pretty crazy
did he get i think he was late last year
uh we didn't catch him because i didn't
have a camera in that specific spot so
he probably was looking for the security
camera the [ __ ] you lied to someone's
trash can on fire for just your head's
attention
i guess so because he did it while i was
streaming
and it like exploded basically and like
made a huge sound against my garage door
so i was like what is that i went out
there and i'm like
oh like i smelled something burning
right so my first thing i first like
looked in the kitchen like do i have any
ovens on or anything i looked at like
the heater and i couldn't figure it out
and i looked outside my my window and i
was like oh my trash can's on fire what
the hell and it had exploded against the
garage door
um i know you you went through something
pretty traumatic but are you feeling
relieved now that he's in custody
yeah that part is very relieving um
i don't know what's going to happen now
though right it's like if he if he
gets out of wherever they've detained or
wherever they've taken him
what's to keep him from trying to come
back at a later time
did you get an opportunity to talk to
the police like please you can't this
guy is you can probably now that he's
done something get a restraining order
if that's something you want to deal
with i don't know
yeah i i think for these type of people
they don't have the mental awareness to
actually follow that so it's still a
threat even if there's more legal
repercussions afterwards
they better just kick him out i mean
what the [ __ ] yeah it's pretty [ __ ] up
i have a follow-up coming up soon
um with the detective on the case
because of course they're always late in
these processes right so i like filed
like you know i told the police about it
and they were starting the case and the
harassment but then this happened and
now they have to escalate it further so
it's just like a waiting game
do you know what charges he got
um
i am not sure all of them no i know for
sure obviously trespassing right because
that's like the given one but i don't
know what else yet i just wondering if
it hopefully is a stiff enough charge
where they can deport him
yeah hopefully that's like just crazy
it boggles my mind too because he
literally sold everything he had
to come over here he sold his house all
of his possessions
i assume sold his first catch well
that's an immigration violation actually
if they find out that's like a violation
of the visa because you have to show
that you have an intention to go back
if you're going for a travel visa so
that is actually a
a tri uh visa violation i don't know
hopefully someone could do something
with that yeah because he said it on his
uh stream too so it's like recorded
verbally from him
so that's that's scary man it's super
scary because with someone who has that
kind of mentality it's like they have
nothing left yeah no you're absolutely
right that's scary if he's got nothing
to lose he sold all this [ __ ]
did uh was there anything weird in his
in his uh did you find out what was in
the saxophone case
uh all i ever saw him take out of it was
a saxophone i didn't see the rest of
what was in there
yeah
so very strange i guess that's good but
it was just the saxophone maybe weird
well i know how easy it is to get a
[ __ ] gun right exactly you're right
to be worried about that
yeah i mean you know people do it
illegally all the
time that's crazy
you ever be like yo i don't want to deal
with this [ __ ] i'm just going to [ __ ]
retire and move somewhere else and just
forget all this
oh
you know i have thought about that but
then i i i think though truly that the
most crazy people who are the most
obsessed won't even stop if you do that
sure
so that's true that doesn't really fix
the issue unfortunately
it sucks that people are so [ __ ]
crazy
in your line of work there's always
someone nuts
like yeah right i mean i mean it's just
it's sad but
it's just
men men are [ __ ] up dude
it's like you said it it's a man thing i
mean
really like
oh [ __ ]
what can we do what can we do people in
the chat saying that he's a sax offender
a sax offender
i don't think there's
honestly anything you can do except try
to be prepared and you know like who can
every situation is a little different
too so it's really hard
to do that much even i would say at
least you have the resources to get a
serious
um security for yourself you know
for sure
so that's good at least
i am in texas too so i'm i'm legally
allowed to defend myself well yeah but
yeah so are you a shooter do you have
experience with guns and knives and [ __ ]
are you ready to throw down if you need
to
i mean i would prefer not to if i had to
i i have gone to shooting ranges you
know i've had some instruction but i'm i
prefer to have an experienced guard here
absolutely because they are less likely
to panic in that situation than i am
even if i have experience absolutely
someone suggested have you thought about
building a moat around your house
i have thought about that when i get my
ranch property i have played the idea of
a moat with alligators and uh that is
honest i wonder if you can illegally do
that like not even kidding like have a
drawbridge
a fat ass [ __ ] moat
you know yeah you could you could put
sentinels up there
because people were trying i mean people
were trying to [ __ ] with kings all the
time
yeah have some trap doors so if they get
near your porch you just
click the button
let me ask you this in texas is it legal
to pour
burning oil on on someone for
self-defense home defense um
i i don't know that's a great question
you know that's maybe one of those
things that better to ask for
forgiveness for and claims that depends
you know burning oil
archery
it broke in didn't know what to do it's
basically a tower defense game your
house yeah
[ __ ] amaranth we can also we can also
have kangaroos in in texas maybe i'll
just get like an army of punching
kangaroos yeah that would be that's
actually that'd be kind of dope you
specific you can get kangaroos in texas
that's a thing yeah it's legal it's
considered livestock
okay
on a lighter note though
oh [ __ ] look at this house in florida
this actually isn't even a joke
can you see this no longer
yo this is a house in florida
it's only 4 million bucks too
oh how is that a four million dollar
house that looks like a freaking yo look
at that they got a moat they're gonna
have to swim to you dude i wonder if you
could make it like acid water too so
they dissolve
supposedly
there's alligators in this water no
[ __ ] way what does this person do
i don't know yeah in florida they have
alligators
right i guess that makes sense for floor
dude that's nuts that's a real thing
there you have it
that's perfect um i want to ask you on a
lighter note since i've got you here
about the fart jars okay
cutie two yes
now though did you enjoy those well i'll
just be honest with you okay i first of
all i appreciate your your
entrepreneurship
but we opened them and we smelled them
and there was no smell inside and i'm
not calling you out
i'm not trying to say i'm not accusing
you of anything but i'm just saying
how soon did you open them when you got
them
like and how soon did you sniff it after
you opened it let me get the details
actually they may have been sitting
there for a little bit they may have
been but
leakage the first one did have a little
bit of something
you said make up your mind no no i
didn't i did say the first one would
have a little no because after the show
you said you didn't smell it first one
because you know amaranth is a fan a
friend of the show when i was by zach
doing the second and third one
i may have been a little
you know is that what happened yeah
did you open it ahead of time
that's a possibility you consumed this
fart privately oh did somebody break
into that [ __ ]
that is that is that is possible but
you're saying look at exactly salt
shaker type jars they're just little
holes and you turn it to sniff i'm
guilty i'm guilty yeah i did a pretty
problem
no no no but you know i'm a big fan of
amaranth but um i be honest i didn't i
smelled plastic or glass it didn't smell
like a um
didn't smell like a fart it didn't smell
like a fart no i don't i'm not trying to
be a dick
that might actually
be even even more proof that they're
real because i didn't use fart spray
that would be that that's what we were
going to say same thoughts
it was overwhelming than it would
actually have been you guys are simpsons
it would have been sustainable
we can confirm
they
well let me just ask you questions uh i
want to interrogate you a bit did you
want to see something olivia no
how many jars did you produce
oh
trying to think about number we were uh
i think we capped it at a thousand so
you sold a thousand of those [ __ ] no
no
they're still there's still some left so
how can you how can you feasibly fart in
a thousand jars it's all in once right
it's just over the course of months i
keep them in the bathroom and you know
like
maybe tmi for some weak people in here
but um you know how before you have to
shake as [ __ ] yeah you have sometimes
you have like it's gas wall that
sputters a bit i'm just like oh you have
a gas yeah so how do you but that sounds
risky how do you know you're not going
to [ __ ] in the glass or did that ever
happen oh no no i i have amazing control
over my [ __ ] we're good you got good
shutter yeah you have a good shutter i
have a good shutter yeah
but still a thousand i mean i'm just
doubting the logistics of that a little
bit how long were you i just wasn't done
with that i'm just asking questions i'm
just asking questions the cap
so how long were you collecting farts
before you sold them
um probably
like
the just the leading up to the promos of
it that week so maybe like i don't know
five days
[ __ ] you collected a thousand farts in
five days no no we haven't done it we
haven't done the full thousand yet i'm
saying the run is
a thousand okay
okay okay okay yeah we've gotten through
at least a few hundred okay
yeah i'm very curious what what your
diet has been
in order to get the farts in the jar if
i may ask
uh i just i consume probably like
you know anywhere from uh 80 to 120
grams of protein
whether it's protein bars or shakes like
a normal like fitness diet and that's
enough for me can i ask you does that
happen does that have any noticeable
effect on the odor
just a lot of protein um
yeah some days where it's been mostly
protein bars it gets a little bit and i
have to get some febreze after you know
it's bad
yeah it's a little bad and so
this is interesting okay
so the ones you sent us were you're
saying they were freshly brewed before
shipping yes okay interesting so maybe
we let them sit a little too long
yeah
i feel like some people they open it
and then they smell it they're like
hesitant we were fast we were fast
they're fast okay good they stuck their
nose right in there boy no they lick
they actually even licked the bottom of
it i didn't know the the hair was a very
nice touch now was that was that a hair
from your head it was yes we just like
where the hell else would it be exactly
we collect them from children i'm asking
a [ __ ] guy bro look at how long the
hair is where would it be from i don't
know dude we're humans we grow hair that
also came out of my [ __ ] so okay
that's you know that could have been the
case yeah she has a long hair a mane of
hair around her [ __ ] dude ask her is
weird i don't know
well is he onto something uh amaranth do
you have a mane of hair around your
[ __ ]
uh only when it falls in the shower and
you have to pick it out and you kind of
like wiping it on the wall during the
shower because you don't know what else
to do with it you don't want to put it
down the drain you know yeah i know of
course
it's like a jackson pollock on the
shower door yeah
okay
so
well
i'm sensing that there is some
legitimacy here
i just want to warn you if you were not
farting in those jars that could be
construed as uh
false advertising
and i would press charges i would i
would pursue charges i'm aware
yeah i would personally truly organic
all all grown natural
homegrown homegrown there we go ethnic
parts
ethnically uh produced ethically
produced i didn't i didn't strain myself
you know
and was it there wasn't there a new
thing you're selling or was that the
there's someone else who's selling their
boob sweat now i don't know ethically
produce would you
ethnically
ethic ethically
i was eating i was eating mexican food
too so both i guess ethnically and
yeah
there are some beans in there both
would you be uh
there's a this other woman's uh streamer
who sells her bodily functions in
similar way she's producing boob sweat
and selling that is that something that
you would consider doing hoop sweat
how do you
how do you capture that um there's a
video she sits out in the sun sunbathing
and she kind of just
has a little vial and just collects
droplets as they form it's like one
droplet
that's that's that's creative
i haven't considered that but i mean you
know capitalism baby
yeah boob sweat or um maybe i um let's
see spit spit would you spit
i think that would be that one would be
very popular if you spit right yeah
i think yeah
you could almost say that's like a
condiment right like on your food
yes it might also be a biohazard
it may be illegal can you ship spit we
we
didn't we yeah it started covid we went
through all of this
i'm not saying it was illegal okay
that's true it could have been illegal i
just want to say that belle del fin spit
also magically evaporated um
okay dude you know how much bacteria was
in that [ __ ] that was after like a year
or two we like found the jar and it was
empty and maybe you drank it i do
toenail clippings would you sell toenail
clippings or nail clips nail clippings
oh interesting oh
that would be a good one you know would
they be like in a jar like sure yeah
just about just like you know like your
farts are now like a keepsake maybe
you know that's interesting ethan that
seems like it would be an obvious one
toenail clippings but i don't know is
there maybe there's no more i guess the
issue is influencers often get pedicures
and stuff so they don't really have
their toenails
you'll have to grow them out a bit right
right you know yeah yeah and then i have
to clip them and then go to the salon
that would make sense
but yeah
you could probably grow
a new set
you know every week at least right maybe
even twice a week
maybe ambitious you know start taking
the collagen pills maybe
so that's interesting um a piece of
toilet paper without a
that's is that too far that's way too
far that's disgusting exactly
what's [ __ ] on
anything it bro oh my god what the [ __ ]
my concern would be leaving my dna like
people having my dna and being able to
leave that like at a crime scene
they're going to find a toenail clipping
at a crime scene they find a lot less
yeah
well if she sells toenail clippings she
got a perfect album that's an alibi how
is she ever going to get convicted she
got toenail clippings all around the
country
true maybe it's genius it's a it's an
alibi yeah that's what it is interesting
okay um hold on i'll be right back my my
assistant needs me for a second should
just take like a minute that's okay
all righty
yeah i'll be right back
so um
everyone's freaking out [ __ ] acts cursed
suggestion right now too shitty
shut up [ __ ] kidding tell you what
i'm seeing
but now what you said toilet were you
talking about like a piece of [ __ ] like
post wipe or with pee on it or what
whatever
i was trying to be funny but clearly
people don't understand this how dare
you try to be funny zach
on a comedy show how dare you
um for anyone wondering i did see a
couple people in the chat um
say that you know amaranth says she's
not doing the boob sweat but uh
but
that their boobs are sweaty right now
and to hit them up so
if anybody was um
interested in that offer there's a lot
of super troopers out there with some
boob sweat
that are uh
[Applause]
wait love just gave a really interesting
update you could talk about it
yeah i
i kind of like like zoned out completely
over this conversation i was reading
this super long legal letter
from
mr beast
you just got a letter from mr b
yeah you guys remember the silly sanka
website i made for the festivals that me
oh cause we made it look like they're
wait what's the website called
uh ian just limited feast of me
oh wait
hold on i just launched no this is is
this not his real website no no no
how did they even find this this must
have zero traffic like what's the
traffic
i don't know
i don't know
dude [ __ ] him this is zonker's territory
wait where's where's the zilli zonk
where you redeem the car redeem your
coast
and then you type something random and
you can just like to yeah anything and
then
it doesn't really matter what you typed
in
this is zonka's territory my guy yeah
love went a lot with this does this mean
some lawyers have been getting like
silly zonked
for sure definitely that's funny wait
hold on so so did they just want you to
remove the website
right yeah so they sent a complaint to
my uh
my uh i i have a web server a giant web
vps or productive server
and they basically the hosting company
reached out to me and said
that
if you don't remove it within two days
they have the right to do [ __ ] and uh
yeah well pretty much that's
well
that's so [ __ ] what is the traffic on
this website can you do you have access
to that no so if i if i want to like
like uh
look into you know or like count all the
views i got to do a bunch of like gdpr
stuff and i didn't want to do that for
this
joke so i don't uh track that i see
yeah well just for racism
yeah i'll definitely just give i'll not
[ __ ] i won't fight this we don't need
this
but it's probably something similar to
what kavkav did
yeah it's dangerous being a website
builder for you ethan
i never heard of this thing and we got
it twice in like six months but to be
fair i guess he has much more of a case
than
than oh yeah because we're impersonating
his company
not even the impersonating it's just a
trademark claim and a takedown note this
yeah it's fine uh yeah i'm just going to
remove them they probably just think
it's a scam site i wonder if anyone ever
actually clicked redeem
yeah yeah yeah because there's no way
they would sue you willingly or do
anything against you willingly like that
but i think not i don't think so either
yeah that's fine yeah if mr beast is
watching this uh i bow down to you i
won't fight you bro
but i think it'd be pretty funny if he
he godzilla should we go should we fight
10 assassins to sweden to find love
the funny thing with all this is it's
always my name i love my last name like
so or
yeah
you can do it if next time you build a
website do it with our company name
yeah i will well i i have a middle
middle company
yeah but use my company so that yeah i'm
the one liable not you sure man billy
zonk is the gift that keeps on giving
the thing
with the cav cap website you technically
made it so they were serving you
right and
we just paid for the lawyer and
everything yeah but i think the k i
don't i have a case that i did it on
like a mission for you guys i
technically sold and i sold the service
for hosting it or so stuff like that
technically maybe i don't know
uh but yeah very interesting very fun
well shout out to mr beast who's suing
that's a good clickbait mr beaster suing
me
that's not even a clickbait
well
mr bass is threatening me with the
lawsuit
he'd be like what
yeah he's like
i i don't think there's a threat of a
lawsuit just to be super technical i
think they're just saying take this [ __ ]
down uh please philly dude you don't
want to see me talking [ __ ] right now
oh for [ __ ] sake
sorry love but it's not
the wednesday show just dropped i'd like
to apologize to ethan klein for not
using him in the thumbnail
even though he is in it for 12 frames
what
bro how dare you use me for 12 thumbs
and not
thumbnail me i noticed billy did
something else too dan if you could open
his video
oh the actual video sure yeah
okay one sec
i saw it on his last episode but then
should i play
yeah play it you can mute it stop what
you're doing he's added a rabbit in his
background
that's [ __ ]
oh
that's steps billy
it's on twitter today being like what
should we name the rabbit
no no no bro
nope that's theft
i'm taking down your channel
i'm doing a copyright
claim him show the thumbnail again he
posted like are you seriously going to
tell me that this pixelated
[ __ ] with two red arrows in a circle
first of all shame on you for using
those
is better than my face hell no
never
he's working against me to make a song
number one
i'm this is outrageous what should he
name the bunny then
judas fraud
yeah jaw rule
[Music]
let me show you to make a thumbnail
this is one from our highlights channel
recently weird and gross
another one
over here
what love
another one of those are coming for you
phillip
today
yesterday by the way it's just a funny
clickbait guy because when you click the
video it was just me complaining that
i'm not in enough thumbnails
my issue with philly philip defranco's
reporting
[ __ ] him dude people are saying where's
cam that's a good point do you think he
you think he he's the one that left
the group today he went
off ship to go work for philly
cam's on a secret mission right now
that's all i'll say about that
highly classified um
so how long we've been going by the way
dan
uh we've been going for two hours and 19
minutes
and uh uh amaranth just came back i'm
back sorry about that cop showed up to
ask about the situation
okay well that's a priority was it a
detective what kind of cop was it i just
i guess a regular one i don't know the
types didn't look any different than
normal
what do you want to know it already
happened i can't talk about what he
wants to know oh
did he ask what was it are you single
no
wouldn't that be crazy if the cop became
the new creeper
sorry the first time i got was a creeper
yeah
so
we were talking about
kind of other commodities from your body
we could sell
oh
yes please give me give me ideas that's
where we left off
by the way is it true that the fart idea
came from me
um a mixture of you and then like seem
to sing the articles of that girl who
got hospitalized which i don't believe
by the way that she was hospitalized for
farts i think she probably got covered
and then decided to spin it and depress
smart while she was there
yeah i believe that's the same girl who
was selling the boob sweat it is it is
yeah
yeah smart girl
[Music]
well um
i'm not sure what else uh maybe maybe oh
do you ever like
scrape your feet to clean them that you
could sell that snarly
i've never thought about that wow pumice
stone
do you think do you think that that's
i don't know like that'd be like dead
skin cells like flakes in it
i don't know
that might be too much
i think the gnarlier the more press
right the gnarlier the more pressure
true
so
do you use makeup wipes
oh that's a good idea
and each one is individual like a
snowflake
oh that's super good
that's true
that's a good idea
i mean
[Music]
how about this zach said toilet paper
hire her
exactly toilet paper and i don't want to
be too hard on zach so let me he might
be onto something let's say
you wipe
and then
the lat you sell the last wipe so it's
basically clean
uh-huh so it's not like covered in [ __ ]
it might be totally clean
since it's the last swipe so maybe you
sell that one thoughts
that could work
it's a it's a billion dollar idea yeah
yeah yeah because it's it has like that
crinkle and like the
faint scent of something was on this but
like not
actually gross
to touch for me
yeah yeah oh god someone said tonsil
stones do you get those
no i don't think that's terrific
yeah that's a that's terrifyingly
disgusting suggestion that is vile
oh
god
i mean underwear is obvious
oh you know like when your chapstick
goes down all the way and you can't use
it anymore there's an idea
just use chapstick but like like all the
way used to chapstick whether it's like
you can't even use it anymore like right
before you throw it away sure
there we go
little stub absolutely thinking like
acrylic nails like they pop off like
these
will like pop off and you could sell
those i feel like someone would buy that
acrylic nails
yeah that's true i like that i do
some horrific suggestions i could clip
the acrylic nails as well so just to
make them last longer
if you were just forgive me this might
be a bit much but i'm just thinking i'm
just spitballing everything ethan yeah i
should have not said it being something
i was ostracized so you might as well
join me
if you ever become pregnant would you
ever consider dropping a a drop of
breast milk maybe in a vial
oh
oh
that's not a bad idea that's not a bad
that wasn't as horrific as i thought
that was some people produce too much so
i mean overproduction of breast milk but
just a drop you know so they know yeah
you're there
yeah
that's a really good idea
all right well if you want any more
ideas you're gonna have to pay for it
i understand thank you for the
consultation this is the first trial you
know the free consultation and
absolutely anything after this
it's going to cost you
well thanks for calling in and sharing
your story i'm glad that that's sorted
let's just hope that it goes away
for good yeah for sure
yeah it's pretty crazy situation and
then a lot of girls are reaching out to
me too afterwards telling me about their
stalker situations and how we should
just like make support groups for this
so we can share ideas for safety that's
honestly a really good idea
i think so
you're gonna have to like home alone
your house some of these girls
booby traps yeah
all right caitlin
take care talk to you soon you too
thanks for
thank you for calling we're glad you're
safe
that's amaranth everybody
hi
thanks for talking to me i appreciate it
all right
nice to see you you too
all right
bye all right
all right dan anytime
any time he takes me
ah i really like her she's she's
she's a smart
she's a really real smart real real nice
yeah i like her
funny
that's a shame man the dudes are so
[ __ ] crazy it's like if you get into
the kind of line of work that she does
or even not let's like if you're just a
woman online
your life is that your life is in danger
thank you
it sucks
well to be honest like she has resources
but there's some women online
that have stalkers that don't have
resources and that's very scary yeah
i've
seen a lot of youtube videos there
there's some series that like tells
horror stories from only fans and so
many girls and only fans get stalkers
and
it's so dangerous
and people are the worst hoof
why did you unmatch me
ben absolutely
you wake up
and this is the first thing you hear
it's me
scary or endearing
yeah we'll never know
why did you unmatch me
what else we got here um
what else we got
britney spears wedding drama it's kind
of old news
old news
and we did technically talk about it on
monday for about
10 seconds so
[Music]
you have this philosophy discussion that
you've been teasing for can we do that
no
okay that's a good idea let's do that
so you know we have these discussion
prompts we do from time to time
and i dreamed this one up as i was
cutting a particular
item
and i thought like man
if this disappeared from the world
tomorrow
we would lose so much we would lose so
much
and then i got thinking and i posed the
question to the crew
if you could select or yeah if you could
select one fruit or vegetable to
disappear where forever
which one would have the biggest impact
on human life
so one fruit or vegetable disappears
which one's going to have the biggest
effect
yep
so
i know there's there's probably a whole
range of answers
some is on the culture some is on like
you know just people being not being
able to eat right like there's that
angle
but everyone gets it everyone has an
answer we've been thinking about this
for a while
so this is very interesting
i see people in the chat already getting
all
right we're passionate about it and
worked up so who so damn why don't you
go first and we'll work around our way
around i have
i have a point of clarification
you save fruits and vegetables now
or just one item
right i understand that it's just a
singular item but
fruits and vegetables aren't like
they're they're they're like
terms are used in botany and stuff but
it's not actually like a hard
like it's a little nebulous of what
qualifies as one or the other and i just
wanted to know
if
you would allow
um seeds grains green seeds
that's an answer okay no okay
because
my immediate thought
was rice yeah rice would rightly kill
everything devastating if rice decided
not rice but if we can't include rice my
next answer
is tomatoes
what you're supporting
for that i believe tomatoes are
the biggest non-grain crop in the world
by like a lot
and they are used in an immense amount
of different cuisines
um
i mean mo i think i can't speak for
other countries but here in america you
know
you probably wouldn't go a day without
eating a tomato product in one form or
the other
ketchup or a sauce or
or just a tomato slice pizza
that's what i was cutting when i thought
that oh really it was a tomato the
tomato okay and i thought
this this tomato which is technically a
fruit right
um
in every culture they have these
incredible dishes all around tomato
salsa
pizza also um
that's all i can think about okay
well
the only two main things you eat
soup mexican food and pizza
nobody confirmed that a b yeah i'm
looking tomato really is the most
tomatoes are the most popular vegetable
they're not a vegetable what are you
talking about stop it well okay they're
technically a fruit you're right thank
you
that that does throw this fact checking
into question doesn't it yeah yeah
but that's the thing is the reason that
there's such a debate around that is
like i was saying at the beginning the
the
the borders between fruit and vegetable
are more nebulous than we were led to
believe as children there's it's not
a hard and fast rule about what makes a
fruit or a vegetable
yeah but the tomato is so versatile man
it has it's incredible this little plump
red little [ __ ]
it it's just transformed all across
humanity everyone uses a vet uh tomato
every ethnicity
every
region look at that it's crazy the
tomato is so prolific a lot like i said
yeah i remember really
it's like
by far the biggest now that's not
including again grains
corn
you know
things that wait this says according to
most nutritionist tomatoes a vegetable
however botanists describe the tomatoes
of fruit that's why
it's it's a it's not i go with the
botanist nutritionist doesn't even mean
anything you don't even need credentials
to be a nutritionist
well fair enough
i go with the botanist but anyway
that's a lot of tomatoes somebody named
oh sweet potato just gifted 10 uh
memberships i think they might be trying
to affect
the outcome of this vote a little bit mr
sweet potato well i'm going to read it
i'm seeing just like potatoes the most
popular
you're seeing what i'm seeing potato
some people are saying potatoes yeah
potato is a big one but but actually
this is real interesting because it goes
tomato
onion
cucumbers
and then cabbage
which i wouldn't expect
cabbage is above broccoli
i would expect like bananas or
potato spinach
to be higher because the potatoes kind
of like rice where it's like everyone
starves if the potato disappears in a
lot of places right but potatoes
aren't a grain
and i guess that i think it's a fruit as
well i see all these people talking
about corn i'm a little unclear on corn
because it is corn technically a grain
no it's a vegetable i think it is a
vegetable oh well i thought it was
starch
maybe the question should have just been
cropped wait zach what's this what if
it's crop it's rice if if it's just crop
period my answer is rice
no no no that's not the question right
that's not corn
corn is a starchy vegetable it's starch
it is a vegetable oh i thought like
maize is made
a
brain yeah but corn is another really
good guess but yeah tomato i didn't know
that was number one by far i mean that's
fascinating
everyone loves the tomato
i'm unclear on this look at this
maize which is what corn comes from corn
is just a variant it's a cereal grain
it's a cereal grain
maybe there's different
i think maybe the old corn is different
from the new corn because it may be like
when it's like developed into like a
corn on the cob at that point it's a
vegetable but when you see like the old
corn back like aztec corn it's like
completely different right yeah yeah the
corn that we know is like a weird
genetic like uh mutation of
the actual crop maybe if you go to like
uh
modern day corn maybe you can get more
intel there
[Music]
people are saying soybean as well that's
a really good one yeah that's a big one
sugar cane
sugar cane might be mmm sugar oh that is
a good answer sugar cane would [ __ ] the
world up but see that i mean that's not
a fruit or a vegetable dude this for
some reason is like the hardest thing
i've ever had to fact check it's all
over the place this is what i'm saying
i've looked all over it before too
because sugarcane is a
grass
interesting a grass corn is literally
fuel what the [ __ ] is this conversation
listen i get it corn is a big one for
sure
and i wasn't purposely excluding corn
it's just it was a little unclear to me
if it qualified because there's this
debate about whether it's a grain can
you look up more stats on the
[Music]
what's the most farmed crop because that
one said vegetable i don't know if it
included i think the most farm crop is
rice
let's look that up what is the most
farmed crop isn't this interesting sugar
is from a grass
right so would it technic
um
oh wait here i'm getting more info on
sugar food commodities it actually looks
sugarcane a metric oh this is in tons i
mean i guess that's a good way of
measuring it so what do we have
sugarcane whoa
the highest
production volume of the most
produced food commodities in 2019
so sugar would yeah sugar is a big one
there man sugar corn
i'm seeing corn
wow
i didn't realize i mean i know people
love corn especially in america we have
like a [ __ ] little corn but i didn't
realize around the world that [ __ ] was
so popular
well and it's it's just used for a lot
of uh
people saying dan hits corn diet do not
put that out there i [ __ ] love corn
corn is over the [ __ ] rated bro
don't you guys feed your life rated
corn are you serious dude uh yeah yeah
yeah cows eat corn yeah i don't think
they do that in other parts of the world
isn't that like a negative in some way
bro it's so stupid we like the
government subsidized corn it's like a
relic of like depression era and we have
so much corn we turn it into sugar and
syrup and feed it to cows it's [ __ ]
stupid
and we just put it in [ __ ] everything
by way of the uh corn syrup yeah the uh
the corn industry uh is um not a great
thing for the planet so i'm not gonna
try and defend it on that mayor but a
[ __ ]
grilled up corn on the cob with some
butter spread across trying to tell me
that
[Music]
what the [ __ ] i'd rather eat something
else
they had corn at disneyland and it was
disappointing
they sell corn on the cob at disney
what'd they put on it it wasn't even on
the cob nothing and then it's a bowl of
corn just a
thing whatever it's called the cob oh i
said corn on the cob have you ever had
mexicans i thought street corn what they
what they season it with so good so
nothing they didn't have anything oh
[ __ ] it was just plain corn what the
[ __ ]
steamed what steamed corn i mean just
steamed they didn't butter it no butter
no salt nothing no cool looking prices
disneyland no way [ __ ] are they doing at
this where really how could they do that
was right canceled disney
that's unforgivable how much you spent
up for that corn how much was it ten
dollars i'll never fifteen bucks for one
corn
no no for me lena two of them so 750 or
something yeah that shit's basically
free in america yeah but they don't put
anything on it nothing i was tallina i
wonder what the profit margin is on one
piece good very good yeah yeah i mean
they're paying 10 cents like 99
yeah
yo
they're really dropping the ball because
you can do a lot with the corn on the
cob
it's my favorite vegetable by a mile i
love corn
it is so i love cream corn i think
that's like one of my favorites okay
i'm on disneyland website and i guess
they do have some with
chili what is this butter philly spice
butter that's like the mexican
mexican okay yeah but the place i went
didn't have anything maybe they were out
i guess it's 5 29.
maybe with tax
maybe yeah you held on to that though
you got burned hard
you never forgot it didn't yeah i was
watching the water show and it was just
distracting me the whole time as i was
eating as i can't believe i paid this
much for corn
lina how was the corn was it really like
abs describing
oh she said it was good oh she's going
against the fence nina liked the corn i
mean it was good it wasn't five dollars
good was it five dollars good lena
she
it's not that bad five bucks for a corn
at disneyland
it's not that bad
i mean i was expecting regular corn and
that's that's what it tasted like there
wasn't any disappointment i was at
disney i thought it'd be some fattening
over the top corn i would i would expect
that
but i am saying i mean five bucks yeah
yeah not that bad
disney was
i i can't believe how expensive that
place is disney as a place is [ __ ] i
don't know how these massive families go
there like low like
middle class families with like 10
[ __ ] kids yeah you have to take out a
damn loan to go there dude it's like two
hundred dollars just for a normal ticket
to one park
yeah
i was something like that i just know
for the whole day me lena was 7.50
wow and we didn't buy anything special i
mean we got the genie pass which was
like an extra 40 each but that's it so
you guys almost spent a thousand for
just all day at disney you felt burned
by that experience
yes yeah i feel like i was too old for
it i don't blame you man a thousand
bucks and did you guys do both parks or
just one both parks you do both parks in
one day yeah we didn't get to do
everything but yeah that's a lot for one
day
uh there's someone in the chat that i
just feel like i have to acknowledge
because they're very consistent about
this um go ahead can we talk about how
good asparagus is
i like asparagus i i want to acknowledge
you i [ __ ] love asparagus asparagus i
love asparagus but it's a niche
vegetable i don't think it has universal
acclaim and how do you prepare asparagus
you basically just like grill it or
steam it yeah that's [ __ ] great or
it's not versatile like these other ones
saying
i think you can do some interesting does
it make your piece smell like farts
it doesn't make it smell like farts i
feel like it makes it smell like
asparagus i smell farts when i eat it
you guys made me try spare just only
because i want to see if my pee and
smelled weird
i have i well i don't really didn't
really like studying to eat too much but
i didn't feel anything you didn't smell
anything
no dude if i have one nibble i can smell
it really insanely strong it makes all
the time i never notice it i never know
really
yeah
sometimes i wonder if i have super
smelling abilities because sometimes i
smell [ __ ] that i don't think i should
have access to
like you've unlocked doors that
shouldn't stay closed like when i sneeze
i can smell it like real heavy it's
disgusting this never happened to me i
have a incredibly bad sense of smell my
nose is not sensitive at all and so you
may
you may be right about the fart thing
and i just don't smell it i don't know
has anyone ever smelled their sneeze
before yes i was just gonna try and see
what you mean yeah kind of like when you
taste blood it tastes like that a little
bit i honestly don't know how to
describe it it's just really gross it's
like a bacteria smell yeah it's just
really gross
i sneeze every time i go outside in the
sun i don't know what it is i don't
that's normal but i've heard people say
that you look up at this side
people are saying it's a jew thing what
the smell what the smelling might be
asparagus is smelling asparagus is
genetic people are saying is that right
oh i mean that may be the case i don't
know if it's a jew thing that sounds
like jews smell it when they eat
asparagus folks
when you guys uh eat cilantro does it
taste like soap at all it's like a dream
oh i've heard of that do you have that
experience zach no no no i do i hate it
no
that's so sad i feel terrible what about
salsa and all the mexican cuisine
i would rather it not have it in it but
i've learned to like
eat it holy [ __ ] i feel so bad for that
yeah that is that is a tragic i get that
with uh parsley parsley tastes exactly
like soap to me it's so bitter
let me read this this is real
interesting guys some people have the
ability to smell
asparagus urine while others do not
this specific um
is or inability to smell a certain odor
is associated with a single
nucleide polymorphism
near the olfactory receptor gene
or2 m7 a protein coating gene so it is i
think i have super smelling i really do
i smell [ __ ] and i
[Music]
i feel like it i i smell it it's just it
doesn't smell like farts to me dude it's
so strong it's like insane get this it's
estimated that between 20 to 50 percent
of people experience it that's it 20 to
50. that's it
i thought everybody got the asparagus
piss
huh i it smells to me but i wouldn't
describe it as a fart smell right that's
good i'm with you zack
[Music]
what can i say i think my super smelling
is more of a curse than a gift i think
because generally in most cases i could
see how that would be a negative not
good yeah
some people say can you smell when the
season change
that's [ __ ] not in la there's no
seasonings
i know i know what they're talking about
though
i mean i imagine once it hits spring and
all the pollen being really pollen smell
that leaves falling yeah yeah
in the city it's hard but being from the
country i know exactly what they're
talking about you can totally smell like
fall right it has a very distinct smell
can we do a poll um
do you smell asparagus in your pee
yes or no asparagus
in your pee
yes
no
i have like super sonic hearing that's a
gift and a curse too you have super
hearing yeah
interesting what
what am i saying right now
bro
what did something about me being an
arab or something no i didn't
okay so yeah i mean that's that's
basically it says 40
40
60 basically just rounding
exactly exactly i've heard you
i was testing him okay
yeah but back to the crops
so we've got kane by far king kane
corn wheat
makes sense rice and wheat are pretty
neck and neck there wheat of course
bread who the [ __ ] doesn't eat bread
corn is like significantly higher than
rice i'm actually blown away by it is
that just america that we're like
[ __ ] up the stats is that just pure
because we turn that [ __ ] into syrup
popcorn
we i mean we eat a lot of uh corn in
europe too i think it's
at least in sweden like popcorn
obviously corn just to the food
corn on the columbia so let's as far as
the corn production it's
you know mostly the uh
what do you call it the being used for
animal feed
that's true used for making ethanol
that's true and being used to be turned
into high fructose corn syrup which at
least in america we put into almost
everything that we eat it's a versatile
vegetable actually you could say that
it's very versatile i don't know if
that's a good thing after rice
after wheat and rice you've got whole
milk from a cow
semen is is another kind of milk does
that include semen or is that just from
a milk this is utter
oil uh the next one is oil palm fruit
which i'm assuming there's palm oil yes
which i know i've heard is extremely
unhealthy
uh there is a decent amount of
controversy around it yes um some people
do actually say that it's
a positive thing because i believe the
uh
the vegetable oil that you get from it
you can you get like per acre of land
that you farm palm oil you get like 10
times the amount of oil that you would
from like just normal so ecologically
positive
but then the places where it grow
they're like slashing and burning the
rain forest to make the plantation so
it's like so there's like it's the worst
yeah it's like there's a lot of yeah
controversy around it so after palm oil
as potatoes
soybeans i have no idea what's the next
one kosova
cassava beans i think what the [ __ ] is
that never heard of the damn thing is it
a fob oh wait i was so wrong i don't
think it's beans i think it's a root
yeah it's a root
flavored starchy root vegetable or tuber
native to south america major source of
calories and carbs for people in many
countries whoa nigeria thailand
indonesia
are top consumers of cassava
yo that's interesting that's like a top
10
product i never even heard of it yeah
it didn't
not use much here being gluten free i
eat a lot of cassava flour things
shout out cassava
is that i if have i had those in salads
sometimes is that what it is where it's
like kind of a flavorless crunchy
type of thing
that's probably not different you're
talking about jicama yeah i'm talking
about jicama
what is it
yo whereas people at my restaurant used
to say all the time jakama
no jakama please
yeah we gotta do barbecue salad but i
don't want any of this here uh jacama
we gotta do a cassava taste test i don't
think anyone in here has had
possibly you know how to prepare it
sam can prepare it yeah we can find
she's a culinary genius and then this is
sugar bee and tomatoes is like way down
the list
barley
buffalo milk
chicken meat
bananas
pork watermelon onion sweet potato
cucumbers apples
eggs oranges grapes and
jerkins that's the same [ __ ] isn't it
like why you white
egg orange grapes yams rapeseed bro i
still can't get over that name
rape seed
yes we don't even say rap seed
which is a little bit more friendly yeah
no here it's straight up rapeseed yeah
it's [ __ ] up you need a trigger
warning before you [ __ ]
talk about this seed
the first time i heard that i thought
people was [ __ ] with me they go yo it
needs you need some rapeseed oil i said
you need [ __ ] you need what
you need rape seed oil
the [ __ ]
yeah
i sent you the wiki page it is
first line is pretty interesting
oh yeah
i did anyone have that same reaction
when you found out there was a country
called uh
niger
[Music]
niger yeah niger that's too i'm not
saying it like that love
oh sorry but i said it actually
like with the right pronunciation sorry
no you're good you're good i'm just not
going to pronounce that country's name
but did you all trip out when you
realized that there was a country called
night yeah i was like seven ethan
okay
so you did
thank you
supposed to be pronounced with that j i
think
so say it
niger
sound like that
oh yeah
i'm kidding don't do that that's
horrible it's french that's why
rapeseed also known as rape
they just they took the seed out
i swear to god that's what it says here
they they dropped the seed that was the
only part that made sense
rape seed also known as rape
or oil seed rape
what in the [ __ ] dude we gotta
we gotta amend the
my seed is all over this place
oh no
what was the context of that that's
disgusting
yeah what was phase banks had sex in the
tree house oh was that when he was
saying goodbye to the faze house that he
was living in yeah my seed like he
[ __ ] all over the what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you yeah
my seed yeah
[Music]
so does anyone want us to talk about
their or did we kind of
blow through that but does anyone else
want to share me and dean are both
tomato
anyone else got an interesting response
my life personally i would say potatoes
just because potatoes were such a big
deal when i was younger
for my family because we were broke and
my fam my immediate family then my dad's
family growing up had like 20 different
ways to prepare potatoes so interesting
yeah
sure you're arab
yeah that's why you guys you guys make
fun of well i am half irish but oh yeah
you guys see me eating raw potatoes yeah
that was one of the snacks just raw
potatoes just raw potatoes oh that was
sasha from [ __ ] attack on but for
real so wait do people actually eat raw
potatoes like is that i know you do but
is that a thing i didn't know i was
about
probably like 19 years old that that's
not normal
i mean what do you like in the chat uh
but they like raw tomatoes so
somebody else potatoes
yeah last time we talked about on the
show i saw some people telling me that
they as well can we do it paul have do
you eat raw potatoes i'm just curious
how many people out there
are raw dogging potatoes
[Music]
we're trying to find the roast of the
raw
uh
who out there is raw dogging potatoes
someone says raw potato and salt that's
interesting you ever do that yeah that's
what it was that's the vibe
that's interesting
do you do you skin it or you eat the
skin you skin it you skin it okay
do you cut it up or you eat it like an
apple
uh when i was older i ate it like an app
well i skinned it then ate it like an
apple when i was a kid it was
my mom with chopped slices oh yeah yo a
clear 10 of the audience eats raw
potatoes that's my people
wow my a potato eater that's very that
is like
statistically speaking that's like
nothing i mean ten percent but they're
out there yeah i'm just glad i'm not
alone that's all that matters lina do
you eat raw potato or were you shocked
when you saw he did that
yeah i was shocked i've never eaten that
before
so did he just pick up a potato and
start getting to it and you're like
what's going on here i did in our
basement that's what happened i didn't
even know he does that i think i was
like cutting fries what
and then he grabbed a piece and just
started like snacking on it like that's
normal and i'm like what's going on
i thought i did it from her whole family
yeah when they were preparing dinner one
night and her mom's from the same
neighborhood as me so i thought maybe
she was up to game but she was like what
are you doing and i was like oh this
isn't normal
that's it man you're salt of the earth
you eat potatoes raw dude
there you have it anyone else
yeah um
i was going to say
any type of citrus fruit whether it be
orange lemon
because vitamin c is very important
to
i think us living yeah we don't get
scurvy you know though we get vitamin c
from the sun
i feel like any type of citrus fruit
might be uh important for survival
so the whole genre of citrus whole genre
of citrus food
the whole family of citrus fruits yes
i i don't want to blow your mind right
now zach but
if you like highest
crop and vitamin c i don't even think
it's citrus stuff
i think like broccoli has more vitamin c
it's kind of crazy
plums i'll look at this [ __ ]
plums have more vitamin c
cherries
chili peppers guavas i'm proven wrong
yellow peppers shocked right now
cantaloupe vitamin that's in
in
parsley citrus
spinach kale
kiwis broccoli
brussels sprouts lemons is number 15. i
was always told that like yeah wow
it's actually a i everyone learns that
but it's actually a uh
not true interesting i mean they don't
have vitamin c right
but
it's not even anywhere close to the most
rich oh
isn't that crazy that's blowing
strawberries oranges you know orange is
even twenty what the [ __ ] they say what
yeah oranges on the bottom like eat
oranges and lemons and [ __ ] no wonder it
doesn't do i bet you look [ __ ] i bet you
that was just like some marketing ploy
by the citrus people there's some old
wives tale or something like that you
know like
i don't know like it's always like
you're sick eat some lemon eat some you
know
well they do that they did that with
um god my thoughts just evaporated
[ __ ]
milk they did that with milk milk is
like very unhealthy and the marketing
people for milk convinced the whole
country that like you need to drink milk
to be healthy
yeah which is like super bad for you
yeah they even had like campaigns with
like when i was a kid with mario
drinking milk right
right right
wow well you've uh
i've learned a lot today they're still
healthy though i mean you know they're
healthy right but i guess what was the
number one [ __ ] number one is um
this kind of plum i guess i'm gonna eat
that next time i get sick
well actually also i hate to blow your
mind but vitamin c doesn't help you when
you're sick
what the [ __ ] yeah sorry i feel lied too
you have been lied to does vitamin like
all those emergency shits again i'm
sorry but that shit's all pseudoscience
does vitamin c help you when yeah it
helps prevent doesn't it dude he's
school um i don't even think it helps
prevent to be totally honest
vitamin c has been studied for many
years as possible treatment for colds
but the findings have been inconsistent
it says treatment for colds or as a way
to prevent colds findings have been
inconsistent overall
experts have found little to no benefit
from vitamin c
for preventing or treating the common
cold
but i will what is good for it is just
drinking lots of fluids so people do
that right right maybe that's they
squeeze it into a glass of water and
they're drinking lots of water
well thank you for teaching me this even
because anything else you want to put
out that i can shatter for you how are
babies made
[Laughter]
it's actually uh flown in on a bird
historic yeah
i knew it
is that interesting though
what about the stark here they did a
whole study this is from
uh
this is a whole study they did
people took vitamin c only after they
got the cold vitamin c did not improve
their symptoms
i i've always thought it was vitamin c
and uh zinc
helps with i don't think zinc does [ __ ]
either
so what you just gotta just drink water
and live through it yeah get the cold
yeah drink water
don't exert your body
that's the best thing you can do
you know awesome well thank you
professor kline you're absolutely
welcome zach
absolutely is whiskey uh doing it with
cold i would say probably not well hot
uh
some nice virginia grown tobacco they
did used to think that though if you
drank a bunch of if you got pissed drunk
when you were sick it would help you
kill the bacteria horrible idea that
just makes you feel good for maybe a
second that's such a bad idea
but yeah that emergency stuff is total
[ __ ]
wow
well all they do is like packed with
vitamin c and doesn't do anything
sorry everybody
so disappointing
anyone else
um i was thinking about cocoa beans it's
definitely not the most
used but it would definitely impact the
world a lot that would be that would be
devastating if we lost that
i'd obviously coffee beans too
oh coffee bean another good one
yeah yeah that would be tragic that
would be no more short
to lose coffee and chocolate
to be fair in most modern chocolate is
like five percent cocoa
but still but you need the cocoa five
percent yeah exactly oh what's going on
people are gifting what happened
a shout out to our word seed family
for 20 gifted sub oh wow
thank you r word seed
ross champion said this one's for uab
lectin and
salt solene
solo9
is a toxic compound
that can be found in raw potatoes
cause diarrhea as i've gotten older i've
heard this um but
did you find you've been affected by
that it wasn't as i've gotten older it
was actually dan who looked it up last
time
and i was like i don't wanna remember
yeah but have you noticed any adverse
effects from eating raw potato no i
think it made me stronger right
also thank you blizzard wuffy for five
gifted subbies the ledge
our word seed family
anyone else
i think we've gone to the bottom of this
whole conundrum here
there you have it
good uh good prop though ethan good
prompt yeah thank you so much guys very
important
it was actually really interesting to
look into
the stats on all the veggies
it was very informative i've learned a
lot sugar cane huh this one still
surprised me yeah
can you source this in another place
because the last one we said tomatoes
were like busting over everyone and that
one has tomatoes pretty low
if we need a third source on that it's
like every source is different i mean
i'll keep looking but in the world
doesn't sugarcane make too much sense
though there's literally sugar
everywhere everything you know
well and i think it depends on how
you rate it because i just pulled up the
wikipedia article
and this one is rating it by
the gross
value
value in billions of dollars and rice is
the number one oh
so you can measure it and metric tons
right i mean i guess it makes sense
because
like when we looked at that chart i was
surprised to see watermelon on there
because that seems like a little bit of
like a niche thing but watermelons are
very heavy and so if we're just purely
going by so what's the best way to to
weigh this to measure this then
one i think like by economic impact that
actually does kind of indicate how much
of it is you know being actually used
around although weight does indicate how
much is being consumed let's be honest
yeah see if i sort it by weight there
you go sugar check here's the top but if
you do it by valve well let's look at
value let's look is the highest number
one is rice
two is is pork
man those poor piggies dude or piggies
[ __ ] it's just sad they're so such smart
critters cows cows are next
what's that chicken and then corn and
then wheat soybeans
eggs potato
just straight vegetables vegetables not
elsewhere it's specified and then the
tomato
so tomato is pretty high up it is high
up there
are you surprised by buffalo milk like
who's [ __ ]
who what's going on with buffalo milk
well apparently the biggest producer is
in india and so maybe just in asia
there's enough people in india to put
that on the map
sure
one of my the other uh countries in the
region to use a lot of it or something
and they're just the bigger producer and
because
maybe because cows are considered holy
in some
in india yeah yeah
there you have it folks
we came here to learn today
and learning we did
in it
um oh thank you gifted subs from again
from oh our word seed family that's 40
more since last time that's another 20
from my good friend our word seed family
oh my god
you can see it getting passed out in the
chat that's crazy that's so cool for 60
total
oh wow that's so nice thank you man
our word see between our word seed
family uh oreo and pea
because they're keeping this channel
they're keeping us in business we've
been our lights on the three of you
um
that's it i mean that's basically all i
got how long we've been going dan oh
we've been going for three hours
because i have brittany drama
swedish food
meme
what does hanger reflex
oh i wanted to do that bring the [ __ ]
anger here
because you guys all did this thing
there's this trend on tick tock
and uh apparently if you put it on your
head a hanger
it forces your head to turn
well then you guys did it i have heard
about this and you found that it's real
right i was
100
thinking this is the stupidest thing
ever this is just a stupid troll thing
to get a bunch of idiots to put hangers
on their head and then i did it i was
like what the [ __ ] this is working
what was the feeling were you just
kind of eerie it's subtle but yeah i
mean you kind of just feel it
twisting your neck when you put it on
give it a shot did anyone else feel the
hanger vibe i did
so i just put it on like this just just
like this yeah and put it on like a
decent amount it'll be tight you know
and then just really relax your neck and
just let
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
it's so tight now
there's like a i i feel i do feel i feel
like a little bit of force pushing you
to the side right pushing it's like it's
kind of weird like the hangers somehow
it's creating force there
yeah i feel the force but
it definitely does some kind of weird it
hurts my
dome yeah there's some kind of
interesting force there
that's hard to explain yeah
it weirded me out
olivia you're sitting there
somewhat confused looking
i'm not really feeling anything
there you go olivia you're you're
rocking in your chair though
well that's a personal choice you know
i'm just saying that may affect the
results
let me try
mine is brokey i don't think it works
but it does hurt
it hurts yeah sam i think you're onto
maybe my head's just like big or
something
your head's about to be indented i'm
really stressing this hanger out it
hurts
yo kevin so kevin spacey was arrested
did we talk about this
we
we did it's kind of interesting
so spacey is like a psychotic
freak
he's not just an essay is he like uh
wait rc r word family donated
family this is too much this is too much
yo he's trying to get yo are you trying
to r word our fans right now
i'm serious he wants us to say shout out
to
the r word seed family yeah
no i mean like spread the oil the r word
oil yeah
thank you brother or or sister
whoever you are
that's very kind very generous thank you
guys
um
what was i talking about yeah so kevin
spacey is a total psycho
um this is so wild
there's this one
detail three of kevin spacey's accusers
have died
since making accusations that's just a
little [ __ ] odd
there was around 14 in the u.s three of
them mysteriously passed away within a
year period and now there's new ones
overseas
dude
that's
freaky as hell how did they pass was it
like weird
one of them was
cancer i'm not sure the other two let me
no cancer that's hard to do that's right
blame kevin for that one yeah that's
kind of hard to pin on him
but um let's see
he got arrested finally
he faces additional charges of causing a
person to engage in penetrative acts
without consent i believe there's a word
for that it's called rape seed
like the vegetable
and i'm not talking about the oil type
well
thank you
the alleges offense took place in london
oh so this he got arrested in england
yeah yeah okay that's interesting
because apparently in america they don't
give a [ __ ] about this [ __ ]
uh two counts of essay on a man in
london essay on a man who's known his
30s in london
causing him to engage in
penetrative sexual activity without
consent you know
it's an interesting way of saying you
know
rapeseed
it's kind of a euphemism it's like no
dude anyway sexual assault on a man who
is known as 30s
in in the
spacey
uk
expected to appear
in court on thursday
that's tomorrow
and they confirmed that he did show up
in the country so
in a statement released to good morning
america at the time of the cps
announcement spacey said i very much
appreciate the crown
prosecution services statement in which
they carefully reminded the media and
public that i am titled to a fair trial
and innocent until proven otherwise shut
up bro we know who you we know you did
it you have like a billion accusers at
this point stop it
oh
we have a we got more
gifted subs from
they're having a oreo rusty
who's the guy who's our other
patron i think they're having a uh
a sub off a sub off yes did i just i
don't want to miss any because i mean
they are
i'll let you know ar ramalee that's the
word
that's what we're doing for our r word
family rameli rameli i don't like that
family ramely grammaly it's a oil
rameli ramelly ramelli rambly rambling
stop
i would never joke about that it's just
a [ __ ] oil
grow up damn
while i am disappointed with the
decision to move forward i will
voluntarily voluntarily appear in the uk
as soon as it can be arranged and defend
myself
he shows up in court let's go
retain council of
pnp
he better get a
license over
in the uk quick right
here's a recap of all the allegations
against uh kev kev kevkev
anthony rapp alleged that kev kev
appeared
intoxicated make it made advances
towards him at a party
while he was 14 stop oh jesus come on
uh spacey stated through twitter that he
did not remember the encounter but he
owed rap the sincerest apology for what
would have been deeply inappropriate
drunken behavior
if he had behaved as asserted
he's like i don't remember but that
sounds like me
in other words
uh in
2020 rap sued spacey for essay
and uh intention intentionally
inflicting emotional distress under the
child victims act wow
15 others came forward with similar
allegations what and though bridge
oh yeah that's so interesting kev kev
was about to team up with cav cav right
right there spacey was about to become
the head of relativity right and
allegedly
i believe the story goes that someone
talked someone else out of it
by explaining
someone else's uh history i'll just say
that i don't want to get too deep kev
kept man we could have had a universe
where kev kev and cav cav
and buddies we're in the same uh
multiverse
15 accusers man
stop it
well
good for the english for getting him
you know
there's one more thing since we're going
this long i'll just bring it up there's
was the sweden food meme love that i
wanted to ask you about
people were joking about that swedish
hospitality is horrible it all stemmed
from this one reddit post
where someone
described they were over their swedish
friend's house
and dinner was ready
and they asked him to stay in their room
while they ate
and that sounds
pretty nuts to an american but i heard i
saw some people saying that's normal
well first of all i wouldn't say it's uh
normal by any means
i cannot talk to my friends and even my
parents about it and it seems to be
more a
generational thing it happened more in
the past because personally it never
happened to my myself
uh and uh but i can kind of see that it
being a thing in like swedish society
and stuff like that but you gotta
remember looking like into
another
uh kind of culture through the lens of
another culture kind of
makes things very weird so
i don't know sweden is a very
individualistic country we have very
little social pressures so like you can
kind of say feeding a guest is a social
pressure pressure because they expect to
be feeded in sweden you don't really
expect to be feeded you know or fed uh
you don't expect to get things uh it's
like way less is way easier and there's
no
there isn't these weird rules here and
there
a weird world like feeding like offering
a guest food okay so let me be even more
can you expect water if you go to your
friend's house
well
you have to bring your own water
this thing happens especially for kids
right that come over yeah so it's not
really for adults uh that that would be
weird obviously uh
but
uh
i remember as a child i used to
have to be home for dinner it's like i
should always be home for dinner and if
someone else had fed me
and i came home home not hungry
my parents would be kind of kind of mad
that i wouldn't eat their food okay uh
so that kind of plays into it too
uh like and like dinner time
sweden is a very very working class
country we all work all day and dinner
is a very like
dinner is the time when you get to spend
time with your whole family
and uh
that's also another reason uh yeah i
could go on and on
well let me read this because
the prompt was what is the weirdest
thing you had to do at someone's else's
house because their culture
religion
i remember going to my swedish friend's
house and while we were playing in his
room his mom yelled that dinner was
ready and checked this he told me to
wait in his room while they ate
that [ __ ] was wild
but then so from this came all these
incredible memes about swedish
hospitality
yeah
wait is this one also related i slept
over a friend's house when we woke up he
said he's going downstairs for a few
minutes after 50 minutes i go to the
stairs to see what the [ __ ] is happening
and they're all eating breakfast they
see me and tell me he's almost done and
will be up soon i'd still think about
that [ __ ] 25 years later
[Laughter]
that is kind of well i don't think that
that happened to a lot of people but
obviously there's some people who
experienced too i mean if you okay so
here here uh
they probably have a friend sitting
somewhere in the house waiting for the
family to finish lunch
swedengate they're calling it the
biggest controversy to rock sweden
actually
since uh
ever forever yeah
we haven't had
since bjorn tried to i don't know i got
nothing
yeah
pov
you are swede visiting your friend's
house
no dinner dinner
yeah
forget about swedes not feeding their
plate kids what about adults having to
bring their own sheets and towels when
invited to spend the night
lived there for 18 years can confirm
that's true
no that's not true that seems that's
like a lot of obviously
uh you got to take account into account
that there's a lot of danish propaganda
coming in here in the mix
and that's a very strong driving power
to this negativity around sweden
these danes obviously are very jealous
of the swedish culture and stuff like
that so they take
any moment to
basically pop in some lies here and
there yeah okay so this is propaganda
yeah most of it yeah
pov you're over at a friend's house in
sweden and it's dinner time
harry potter under the stairwell
[Laughter]
hospitality spectrum let the guests
starve on the left sweden and on the
right as brazil force the guests to eat
right yeah
that's funny
yeah we have i mean i that's the thing i
kind of like with sweden we have very
very little social
pressures
like when i went to the us people kind
of wanted to small talk when i was in
the store just random people like if i
said
if i was standing still beside someone
they sometimes like try to small talk
with me and i'm not into that [ __ ] uh in
sweden everyone walk straight ahead
don't talk to each other in the bus we
don't sit next to each other it's really
nice for
them
yeah i'm so so nice i mean sometimes you
don't have a choice though i don't think
people want to sit next to each other
it's just crap there's this meme in
sweden where we have these long buses
like
and every seat is
every double seat is just one person
sitting at every place and then before
someone sits next to someone people will
start standing in the aisle that's
intense that won't happen here yeah
people will definitely take the seat
here yeah no no no
i [ __ ] would sit down quick i want to
stand my stomach grumbled while at my
swedish friend's house and they took me
out to the backyard and broke both of my
kneecaps
that one is true of course yeah
swedish families eating dinner their
guests swedish people don't feed their
guests explain this then sweetie you
make sake wait what the [ __ ] is this
midsummer night it's gonna be mid-summer
you haven't seen that it's exactly is
that from a movie or some [ __ ] a horror
movie oh oh [ __ ] okay but it's not
really a horror movie it's just reality
it looks like a whole thing
it's a documentary actually [ __ ] up
movie dude
it's not too bad that shot's really good
yeah so there you have it do you like
the end of the day
i like horror movies that are like
more a mix of suspense and thriller i
don't like straight horror movies i
think that i think you would really like
that one then
mid-summer okay did you watch reddit
what is it
hereditary yeah hereditary's really no
no oh yeah same creator
similar vibe hereditary scarred me for
life that's the scariest thing i've ever
seen oh my god i thought it was so funny
when the mom ran across the ceiling my
friends and i were just like no
let me say blair witch is an example of
a movie i don't like because it's just
horror for the sake of war i feel like
uh-huh uh it is there's really no plot
and then there there's a lot of movies
like that like uh
well that movie kind of spawned a whole
sub-genre of those found footage kind of
uh movies yeah well i'm not afraid for a
while but
summer is is uh
is
more
in line with what you just described
like get out was a [ __ ] awesome movie
like head to toe yeah that's a great
movie you know that one
so would you put a new one
yeah yeah
what's it called mid-summer no it's a
new jordan peel movie um oh uh
nope nope
you're gonna watch the new jordan
peterson
movie nope
gonna see george get out
jordan peterson movie
that one's called jordan peele someone
called
[Laughter]
jordan peterson's new film my
grandmother's pubic hair oh he could
make a hell of a horror movie i dreamed
i saw my maternal grandmother sitting by
the bank of a swimming pool which was
also a river
her genital region was exposed dimly it
had the appearance of too much
hair
you didn't need to share all that it's
[ __ ] weird
yes
so do you would you could describe
midsummer more of a get out type of film
or like more of a just yeah
actually i well
it's more gruesome twisted i don't know
i didn't more twisted that i know a lot
of people love it though i wasn't i'm
not watching this i hate being scared i
hate horror movies
yeah [ __ ] that i love horror movies
i'm not super big into horror movies but
i i did enjoy that one
let me check the reviews they got really
good reviews
yeah it did yeah it was a very like
critically acclaimed 83 around tomato
7-1 on imdb
there's kind of a rule of thumb in the
horror community a24 okay you got to
give any horror movie like a 15 bump on
rotten tomatoes you think so critics are
notoriously hard like they don't like i
get it though because most horror movies
are just not the plots aren't good
enough
yeah yeah and i mean even like the most
acclaimed horror movies um the shining
probably the [ __ ] reviews
i mean i think kubrick was probably
immune to that bias but
let's see let's see
again it's always interesting to go back
and look
85 percent
which is good but it's not great like
you look at movies today sure
you know it's interesting to go back and
see
like taxi people think uh that's a
that's a classic right
you would think that that would have
what year was it is it this one 1978
taxi talking about taxi driver because
you're looking at this yeah no this is
looking at the danny devito the axiom
you expect
hoffman's first taxi all right you would
expect this to have great oh it does
yeah that one that one was like a big
deal at the time
so never mind
contemporary reviews pretty high
there you have it
all right that's about it for today um
tomorrow morning is
leftovers day leftover and on friday i'm
just gonna say we got something big
big up
big episode on friday from tremendous
it's a tremendous episode folks
people say it's the best episode
ever produced people
keep telling me
they tell me
they tell me no one will ever produce an
episode like this i'll just give you a
big fat kiss
you're gonna love it it's the best
episode of anything ever made
all right
see you guys tomorrow morning thanks for
watching everybody it's a marathon eh
three hours 23 minutes yo did you know
that queen latifah is playing like an
action hero that [ __ ] is so weird
and the pun she's like
bro i swear to god is so [ __ ] weird
queen latifah action show do you know
what i'm talking about no a bro the
equalizer the equalizer is [ __ ]
is [ __ ] la queen latifah dude
it's so
weird now that was a good taxi movie
with queen latifah that's what i was
jimmy fallon queen i thought i thought
maybe ethan was making a joke about that
yeah tom brady's wife was in it what
about the equalizer
no there was a taxi driver movie with
queen latifah and jimmy [ __ ] fallon
yeah good flight dude
no yes so here's queen latifah as a
hard ass
badass uh
batman-esque okay queen i see it go off
queen
yeah
i don't know bro i'm just not buying it
i'm sorry
just not buying it
with peace and love
she doesn't look that it should actually
it doesn't look as bad as i thought
but she used to be bigger
i thought she was bigger
no
she's always been a queen she's always
been a queen
we love our we love them
shout out equalizer
almost got it out with getting in
trouble
almost trying to
scare it a little bit by bringing up
tactic
what did i say is so bad
she used to be fatter okay what can i
say
it's hard to be an action star if you're
fat
like are we gonna pretend like that's
not true
she's not as fat i said it doesn't look
that bad now she lost some weight
you gonna think i'm the equalizer no i'm
not playing the equalizer
i'm just saying you know
you could be ryan gosling equalizer keep
cranking up that music louder louder not
me
crank it
[Music]
you